>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Ted Widmer: Good
afternoon, everyone.
My name is Ted Widmer.
I'm the brand new director of
the Kluge Center and really happy
to welcome all of you here.
Some of you came a great distance.
And it's an honor to host this
important event today organized
by Toyin Falola.
I came from not all that far away.
I came from the city of Providence,
Rhode Island where there is a small
but thriving Liberian community
and a growing abundance
of African restaurants, which
one of my sorrows at moving
to Washington is I don't know
the local restaurants as well
as I did where I come from.
But in our old northeastern city,
this new immigrant population
constituted a really important
source of vitality.
So we're all looking forward
to this conference today.
And I want to thank Toyin
Falola for organizing it.
I also want to pause briefly to
acknowledge my-- I joked yesterday,
my predecessor's predecessor's
predecessor's predecessor,
Carolyn Brown who is
here with us as well.
The Kluge Center was created
with a gift in the year 2000
from John W. Kluge to
the Library of Congress.
It's still the largest gift that
ever has come to the Library
of Congress and it is a center
for scholars doing research
and for public events
such as this one.
And we're so grateful to have Toyin
in our community which
he is deeply in.
He serves the Kluge
Center in many ways.
He's on the Scholars Council
which is a very distinguished
board appointed by the librarian
of congress to give
advice on a range
of scholarly issues
to the librarian.
But he's also very much
among us on a daily basis.
He has an office down the hall.
He comes to all of our events
and we're really grateful
to him personally, as
well as professionally
for all that he brings to us.
Toyin is a professor
at University of Texas
and specifically he's the Jacob
and Frances Sanger Mossiker Chair
in the Humanities and University
Distinguished Teaching Professor
at UT Austin.
He's also a fellow of the
Nigerian Academy of Letters,
a fellow of the Historical
Society of Nigeria,
the author of numerous books
including "Violence in Nigeria:
The Crisis of Religious
Politics and Secular Ideologies",
"the Power of African
Cultures", and "Nationalism
and African Intellectuals".
He's also the series
editor of "Rochester Studies
in African History and the
Diaspora" and the series editor
of "Global Africa" by
Routledge, and also series editor
of "African Histories and
Modernities" by Palgrave Macmillan.
Actually as I continue to read,
I see he's series editors
of a few more.
"Carolina Studies on
Africa and the Black World"
and "African Identities" with
Cambridge University Press
and he's the co-editor
of the "Journal
of African Economic History"
and the "Yoruba Studies Review".
And he is well known to
all of you here today
and he has personally
invited you here.
So he is the person you
really should listen
to to get things underway.
But I'm personally very happy to
introduce him and to thank him
for all he does for
the Kluge Center.
So please welcome Toyin Falola.
[ Applause ]
>> Toyin Falola: It's a
pleasure for me to be here.
We've agreed as to how we are
going to divide the short time
that we have, five people,
encouraging each one to
speak for 25 minutes.
Although Ken Harrow said he
will speak for 30 minutes.
So that we can manage our time
efficiently, we will take questions
at the end because if we stop paper
by paper, we will run out of time.
I have to follow the convention.
As you can see, I am wearing
some of my tight shoes.
And usually I'm supposed to bring
greetings to some of the kings
that I represent and greetings
from three of them as I usually do
so as not to violate the convention.
The long introduction of
the speakers is in the piece
that I took, so I'll be very brief.
Starting with Ken Harrow
who has done a lot of work
on African cinema,
he has been teaching
at Michigan State for
a long, long time.
And he's done so many major
books, including the latest one
by Indiana University
Press on "Trash:
The History of African
Cinemas Viewed From Below".
He's very well known in the academy.
And then we have Abdul Bangura
who speaks close to 20 languages
and is currently-- had in
Arabic, Hebrew, and hieroglyphics.
He is extremely prolific
in languages and he serve
as a special envoy of the African
Union Peace and Security Council.
He is current successor
in this role.
I'm involved in the South Sudan
Peace Mission myself at the moment.
And he's done so many
books, so many articles,
and he's at the moment
researcher-in-residence
at the American University.
Then we have Nemata Blyden who
is in the History Department,
International Affairs and
Director of the Women's Program
at George Washington University.
She's done a lot of work
on women in Liberia,
African and African diaspora.
She's lived in the Africa,
the Soviet Union and in the US
as she brings all these locations
into bearing as she reflects
on a wide range of topics.
And then we have Moses Ochonu who
is a noted public intellectual.
He writes op-ed pieces on a very
regular basis at The Chronicle
of Higher Education,
the Time Magazine,
Global Post and many others.
And he's done three major
books, all very well respected,
including the finalist
for the Herskovits and is
at the moment working on
what Nigerian Muslims think
about Imperial Britain in the
first half of the 20th century.
Please join me in welcoming
all of them.
You want to take a seat?
[ Applause ]
Please come and take your seat.
Let me start.
And my PowerPoint is
there but my interest
in this topic has expanded
very widely.
And last year, when I gave
the usual presidential speech
of the African Studies Association--
By the way, those of you who are
involved with the association,
one of the reasons why people
don't want to serve is because of
that speech, because it's
so difficult to write.
What I did was to map out how a
new discipline can emerge arising
from this topic.
I was taking a lot of risk because
for that discipline to be created,
we have to fragment what
is called Black Studies
or fragment African-American
Studies and either drew an insertion
of the new field that I proposed
which was very well received.
Turn it into a separate self-field
on its own in the academy.
And I have been-- like an onion,
I've been peeling this
project in various dimensions.
And I ran into one of the Kluge
staff in the train one day
when I was going for an interview.
And since September, I've been doing
a lot of interviews in three states,
in Virginia, Baltimore and DC.
I thought I'll be able
to report on this
but they're crunching all
this data for me in Austin.
But I've been able to
cover associations.
I'm now on comfortable
ground talking
about immigrant associations.
Unlike the big state of Texas, it's
so much easier to do research here
because of the density and the
nearness of all of the spaces.
And I'll be reporting on
this data in due course.
Is there a way I can
control it from here, sir?
>> The thing right next to you.
>> Toyin Falola: Where is it?
Oh, this one?
>> Right.
>> Toyin Falola: OK.
So, I've been preceded in
this by a variety of scholars.
The trouble is that many of
them are based on conjectures,
in which they do personal
reflections.
And the reason is the
options for quantitative data,
the options are very limited.
We can rely on the
limited census data
by the federal government
that exists.
And then we can do sample data which
we can collect from specific places
like in Western campuses
which I've done.
We can-- And for instance
we have figures
to say how many Africans
scholars at yield?
That is available.
That's not a problem.
Or how many, you know,
students that are white?
That one we can do.
Or we can do specific research and
we can just take a narrow topic
and then they answer
specific questions.
That we can do.
And then you have a variety
of official categorization
that we can follow up on.
So, I've gone beyond those to do
what is called snowballing samples.
I've interviewed various
locations, Houston, Dallas, Chicago.
I was to go to Minnesota this summer
but it didn't work out because if--
I do not know how many of you are
following this story which a number
of people from Somalia, some young
people, there are four of them,
who are arrested for joining ISIS.
And the community became very angry
that some members reveal
the identity of these kids,
and there's a lot of tension
on that to cancel that project.
So in doing snowballing
samples, there's no time for me
to explain these limitations but it
has been very effective in trying
to see how a new set of data
can compliment existing ones.
Here are the problems.
We have double counting, double
counting in which children born
in the US and children born in
Africa, parent's identification
of children's nationality
are very complicated.
And double counting in so
many snowballing samples,
the percentage is very high,
and also self-identification.
By self-identification I mean
that somebody can say she's
American but she's also Nigerian.
And accounting for that
self-identification is
very difficult.
Even universities, it
has been very difficult.
Part of the complication is
issues around dual citizenship,
in which a person like
me, I carry two passports.
When I'm leaving the US
I use Nigerian passport,
when I'm coming back
I use the US passport.
And sometimes I have a third one
which is a diplomatic passport.
So, that notion of dual citizenship,
whether it's a federal census
or the ACLS, has created
its own complications.
Then you have the tendency
for naturalized Americans
to also call themselves
Africans so that this--
it disconnect both in
the official figures.
I know that figures between
citizenship by birth,
citizenship by naturalization,
and what people see.
Then you have how ethnicities
define itself.
In many African ethnicities, you
claim the birth place of your dad.
So if you are to go to an American
campus and you run to a negro person
who has never left the US,
the student may tell you he
or she is evil but he has never--
he or she may not have
left the country.
That's not uncommon.
And those complications
make it extremely difficult
to use many of these samples.
In Dallas this summer, I was looking
at kids who got into drug problems,
and parents who are trying to adjust
the citizenship definition based
on another variable of shame.
So, then you have-- which you have
for all immigrant populations
undocumented labor.
So if we go by official figures,
this is the US figures now.
And they tend to be lower than
what alternative sources tell us.
In 1960, 33,000 Africans, in 1970,
80,000, we need to put that 1%
of the total population,
and in 2007, 1.4 million.
The figure expanded in
the '70s for two reasons.
First, preference expanded as
people began to come to the US.
People who used to come to the US do
so because they can speak English.
And they tend to go to
former colonial masters.
People in Angola will
go to Portugal.
People in Senegal will go to France.
That's very common because if
language is a problem in migration,
if you can't speak the
language, it's difficult--
adjustments become difficult
and insertion becomes difficult.
But as European economy
enters into this problem,
they began to come
here in large number.
So today, for instance, at Harlem,
there were a large
number of Senegalese.
They've created a Senegalese colony.
And then you have the crisis in the
'80s in Liberia, Ethiopia, Somalia
and Sudan, special
category of asylum.
And in this special category
of asylum, more Africans came,
and in this asylum, they
changed the dynamics of location.
We know those who come voluntarily,
where they stay in the US.
But with respect to asylum,
the federal government
dictates where they go.
So that's why you now
find Africans in Dakota.
On their own they won't
go to Dakota.
It's just not going
to work for them.
So by 2022, according to
the US federal figures,
there'll be 3 million
Africans living in the country.
Is that a big number?
Well, some people would say
it's a small number relative
to the rest of them, foreign bond.
We've been able also
to break distance
down into where people come from.
With West Africa, having
almost 29%, Northern Africa 17,
Eastern Africa following
and then North Africa.
And the largest populations are from
Nigeria and Ghana, Ethiopia, Kenya,
Somalia and East Africa and Egypt.
We're able to know where people
come from and the various numbers
in terms of-- And we're also able
to know where they go to, New York,
Washington, DC, Atlanta, Los
Angeles, Minneapolis-Saint Paul.
These have the highest
numbers of people.
And then you have them
Columbus, Ohio, Baltimore,
Providence, Rhode Island.
And we can discuss what this
means in terms of what they do.
There are variations in
some of these numbers,
as you find the higher number
of Ethiopians in Dallas.
And you have a large
number of Ghanaians
in Chicago, Columbus and New York.
Then we have the Cape
Verdeans in Providence.
And you have a lot of, in DC, a
lot of Ethiopians and Nigerians.
And in Minneapolis you
have Somalian, Egyptian.
LA and San Francisco, they were
from Egypt, Nigeria and Ethiopia
and then when-- This
population is highly educated,
extremely highly educated.
When we draw in the asylum seekers,
we-- you find them in North Dakota,
Minnesota, South Dakota, Maryland,
and the District of Columbia.
And the advantage of this is that
it makes research much easier
and it makes snowballing easier.
As we do some of this
research, we begin to find how--
My eyes is not very good.
I can't see the PowerPoint.
We begin to find how there's a lot
of disconnect in the literature.
The reason why people migrate is
similar to why Italians migrates
to what are the-- why the
people migrate, but we have a 3%
that does not conform
to any of this data.
In other words, they are not
migrating for political reasons,
they are not political exiles
and they're not spending money
that they make in the US.
Rather, they are spending the
money that they made abroad.
So that represent doesn't
plug into the narratives.
As of today we have tremendous data
to support to our broad topics.
We now have solid data or
movements of a time between Africa
and the West, including Europe,
and most recently Eritrea.
Not the tie is pretty
well established.
And the European Union is also very
good in giving us a new set of data.
And then we have data about
adjustment on political exiles,
ethnic and religious associations.
We now have close ties
on Pentecostalism.
As a rising force, we now have solid
data on Pentecostalism, on Islam,
which Abdul will be talking about.
Occupations and entrepreneurship and
how immigrants call us are trying
to frame a variety of topics.
Then we have data that do
not conform to what we find
in established literature.
One of the data that
doesn't conform is I believe
in immigration literature that
it's poor people who migrate.
The data from Western and Central
Africa is telling us the opposite,
that it's people with
resources who migrate.
That's not what we teach in schools.
It is the children of parents
with money, or people with money
who actually tend to migrate.
And we also are beginning
to have data on education
and it's frightening in terms
of how US figure and sample data
in Baltimore by federal
government officials conclude
that African immigrants
are the highest educated.
That's what the data is saying.
Well there's a disconnect between
job satisfaction and education.
And almost 40% say that
they are not very happy.
And the reason has
to do with the fact
that many cannot relate their
diplomas to the jobs they do.
So there's a disconnect,
and a very large percentage.
When as you take Uber or you take a
taxi, you will notice that for many
of those African immigrants,
they already have degrees,
PhD statistics, MA chemistry,
and that disconnect is well
in a wide range of our
society and complain
that although they are
educated they are not happy.
Then you have what we did not expect
to find in snowballing samples,
which is that migration is framed as
an alternative to home conditions.
But a large percentage says
that they made a mistake.
We're not expecting to find that.
We're expecting to say that they're
happy that they've left Ghana
or Sierra Leone, but that's not
what we've been able to find.
And we've been asking the
questions, why are they sad,
why are they not very
happy with this issue?
And there are so many answers,
but two of which are
very important issues
around what I call cultural capital.
What is it that you have
before you come here?
And issues are on social prestige.
Values of social prestige
are not universal.
For instance, it was when I got
to the US that I washed a car
for the first time in my life.
A professor doesn't wash
cars where I come from.
Nobody does that, because of
the higher social prestige
of the professor.
What you call a business card, I
can write a note at the back of it
and it will give you a job.
Not here. That's why I
don't carry one anymore
because I quickly realize
that it's just an address.
It's just to say I'm in Austin.
It's not tied to issues
around prestige.
And you find and later in Dallas
and Houston how they've been trying
to recreate those notions
of social prestige.
I once attended a party
as part of this research
and with the celebrant came into
the hall with a white horse.
So, we find that that is problematic
in terms of what the host think
about them and what they
think about themselves.
And then you find the bigger
issue, do you want to go back and--
I'm skipping because
I'm running out of time.
And we have the percentage
of those who go back.
Very quickly, here's
what is going on.
We've been able to track those
who go back and been able
to track them to where they go to.
But the percentages who comes
back, and there's a distinction
which is very clearly
reflected between men and women.
More men want to go back to Africa.
Most women don't want to go back.
And the decisive answer
is tied to patriarchy.
Because in many times laws
and divorce regulations,
they are very different, although
some countries in South Africa
and Kenya are beginning to
revise many of these regulations.
But for most of Africa,
the women don't want
to go back, which is very clear.
When we collect all these
data, there are a number
of theoretical paradigms that we
have to reflect upon and shift some
of the existing arguments.
For many of you who have read
for instance "Things Fall Apart",
"Ambiguous Adventure",
and many of the classics
in the African writing series,
the trope is that of alienation.
And it's very well established,
but that has to be modified,
because this trope of
alienation is no longer useful.
There is a-- we have to
look for another explanation
because that longstanding
literature--
and I'm sure maybe Ken Harrow
is going to disagree with this--
is no longer working with this
set of African immigrants.
Today, you can live in DC and
not watch American television
for the rest of your life.
You can watch Nigerian
television station.
You don't have to watch Hollywood.
You can watch Nollywood.
So you don't have to put
hamburger in your mouth
for the rest of your life.
You can just eat your
food as a Ghanaian.
They sell them here.
Just as the director
said about restaurants,
there's so many restaurants,
African restaurants here,
Cameroonian restaurant, Ghanaian
restaurants, Nigerian restaurants.
So you can get your cassava and yam
and you can communicate rapidly.
So, we have to change our concept.
What do we call them?
I think they are more
like transnationalists
because of the heavy traffic.
You still can go to Ghana
tonight if you have the money.
And because they are
transnationalists,
we have to find a way to reframe
some of the arguments on the table.
Then you have two contentions,
one back to the [inaudible]
on cosmopolitanism and it's
been advancing this project.
And [inaudible] has connected
more with people in this part
of the world and his argument is
don't walk with people in Africa.
His cosmopolitan argument
has been very problematic
on the African side.
And then you have issues
around Afropolitanism
in which a new generation is
now working within the paradigm
of nationalism of Du
Bois [inaudible].
They're working with another set of
nationalism, [inaudible] and others,
[inaudible] the musician, redefining
the notion of Africa based
on the space that they occupy here.
So we are at the frontier
of a new topic
and I'm sure my colleagues was--
I've just done some
small introduction to it
and there was plus some of
these in greater detail.
Let me call on our second speaker.
Nemata, yeah, you're next, right?
Yes. Is it?
>> Moses Ochonu: Moses.
>> Toyin Falola: It's Moses.
OK, Moses.
>> Moses Ochonu: Thank you.
>> Toyin Falola: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Yes. And do you have a PowerPoint?
>> Moses Ochonu: Yes, I have.
>> Toyin Falola: OK.
I couldn't see.
My eyes are bad.
I can't see.
>> Moses Ochonu: I want
to thank Professor Falola
for inviting me to this event.
And I want to also thank the Library
of Congress, the Board of Scholars
for extending this invitation.
And I want to thank you
guys for taking time
out of your busy schedules
to be part of this event.
I am deeply implicated in what we
are here to discuss, obviously.
I'm an immigrant myself.
And as Professor Falola was
going through his slides,
I could see myself in
some of those slides.
some of those slides,
so it'll be really interesting to
sit up here and try to reflect.
It's almost like what they used
to call self-study,
right, in those days.
And, you know, when I was
in grad school they said,
my professors warned
me, don't do self-study.
Don't study yourself.
So, but I'm here this-- to talk
about why Africans come to America.
It's a pretty self-explanatory
title for the talk.
I don't have all the answers but
my aim is to raise some questions,
some of which actually I
think piggyback on the points
that Professor Falola
raised earlier.
So I'm going to raise those
questions with regards
to motivations, what
motivates Africans to come
to migrate to the United States.
And I'll raise those
questions and I'll put
on the table some tentative answers
that we can talk about in the Q&A.
All right.
So, the classic African migration
story has been told in the idiom
of economic [inaudible] and of
destitution and displacement.
Many scholars and observers
advance economic pressure
and other involuntary
factors as the primary drivers
of African migratory itineraries,
especially when the migration is
from Africa to Euro-America.
In this spring, African migrants
in America are economic refugees.
Voluntary strategic migration
to America is often buried
under this paradigm of
forced exile and escape
from imminent death or destitution.
This overarching motive of economic
and personal danger is extended
to African professionals who
relocates to America as part
of what's called as--
have lamentably called
the African brain drain.
It is also applied to an
increasingly strategic
and voluntary group of
African migrants to America,
Africans whose migration
stories hardly conform or fitting
to the familiar paradigm of
escape and economic desperation.
On the line that notion that
Africans are migrating away
from their continent
for economic refuge
in America is an understanding
of Africa--
African migration as a novel
phenomenon, or as a new phenomenon,
a modern event threatening the
demographic and economic fates
of both the origin and
destination of such migration.
It is sustained-- This idea is--
This belief or this argument is
sustained by illusion of Africans
as traditionally on adventures, and
people who can only be separated
from their homelands by
existential pressures.
The truth, however, is that much
as African migration to America
and other countries of the global
note has accelerated in recent times
and has indeed been affected or
induced by economic collapse,
dysfunction and crisis,
voluntary migration
to far-flung lands has always been
a defining social characteristic
of African societies.
And I'm a historian.
I should know this, and we can
talk about this more in the Q&A.
This voluntary strategic migration
has often occurred alongside
involuntary ones.
But it has often been
overshadowed by stories of dramatic
and violent removal
or escape from Africa.
Given this backdrop, I would
like to introduce and argue
and alternative thesis of
African migration to American.
One that will I argue become even
more relevant in the coming decades
as the mobility of skilled
and talented workers increasingly
defy international borders.
This thesis may not explain
the majority of cases
of African migration to America but
it is increasingly proven useful
as a way to understand newer
generations of migrants.
My thesis here is quite simple.
There is a motivational shift
occurring in the familiar story
of African migration to America.
It shift away from the
economic refugee paradigm.
African migrations to America
are not always attributable
to economic reasons.
An increasing number of African
immigrants resist this category
of economic refugee.
They resist the category
More and more Africans self-- more
and more Africans, self-selected
and well-educated are relocating
to America from their homelands
in Africa not to escape poverty
or danger, but for adventure
and the pursuit of intangible
psychosocial conveniences.
This migratory process outside the
refugee paradigm has been going
on for a long time and has
been growing in proportion
to the overall growth
in African migration
to America in recent decades.
Yet, it has gone unrecognized
because of the long terms
on the part of Americans
and Africans alike
to highlight migratory motivations
outside of the refugee frame work.
These were long terms to see
the African migrant outside
of the refugee narrative stems from
multiple factors, I would argue.
The trope of refuge and
induced exile sustains
for many Americans the avuncular
humanitarian gaze on Africans.
It enables them to assume
that self-defining position
of helper, nurturer and savior.
Americans' sense of their
paternal mission works only
by imagining the African
migrant as someone in need
of American paternal attention.
Paternalistic American attitudes
towards African immigrants walk
better when the migrant
is theorized as a refugee
and as a displaced hopeless
and helpless basket case needing
the help of good natured Americans.
For Africans, including migrants,
sustaining the refugee narrative
and suppressing migratory stories
outside of it is a strategic effort
to leverage the humanitarian
"White savior complex" of Americans
to obtain empathy, legalization
and access to resources in America.
The logical endpoint of my argument
about recognizing the importance
of psychosocial motivations
is simple.
Africans are not very different
from other peoples of the world,
and this is a point that
Professor Falola made earlier.
Like Europeans, Americans,
Asians, and others,
Africans do not migrate
only because of poverty,
hardship destitution
and helplessness.
They also migrate because migrations
sometimes make you feel better
about yourself.
Sometimes migration is,
to put it quite simply,
its own justification,
its own reward.
It satisfies an innate
human psychosocial desire
to explore the unfamiliar,
the other,
the distant, and the different.
For those who could
afford to migrate or those
who can afford migration, spend
in a lifetime in one corner
of the world is unappealing.
Many Africans are in this category
and their story is quite important.
Well, this story goes untold
because there's little appetite
for it in the West, in America.
To advance an alternative thesis
of African migration to America,
especially one that embraces a
more universal generic motivation
for migration is to make a larger
argument about racial essentialism.
It is to argue against
the notion that biological
and genetic signatures
confer innate,
inescapable socio-behavioral
propensities
that differentiate Africans from
Euro-Americans in a fundamental way
and make their migration
stories different.
To be sure, my thesis is not a
disavowal of the obvious economic
and existential stimuli
driving African migration
to the United States.
Rather, I'm trying here to
synthesize the economic push factors
on the idea that migration is also
a quest for psychosocial relief.
If we must account for the range of
motivations for African migration
to America in the 21st century, we
have to embrace an explanatory model
that recognizes the obvious
economic motivations,
as well as the increasingly
significant factor
of convenient relocation.
One does not have to discount one
factor in order to stress the other.
The psychosocial factors
that influence some African
migratory decisions are not removed
from issues of poverty and
economic alienation either.
In fact, I would argue that
there is a symbiotic relationship
between the economy of suffering
and the psychosocial quest
that I am trying to
enunciate in this paper.
Psychosocial longings are sometimes
coextensive, I would argue,
with poverty, although, albeit
a different kind of poverty.
And I'll talk about this
different kind of poverty shortly.
It is obvious that poverty
and economic destitution make
people want to move to places
of perceived economic opportunity.
This is quite obvious.
It doesn't have to be explained.
But if we define poverty
and hardship,
not only in starkly economic
terms but also in terms
of what one may call the quality of
life poverty, then it is possible
to see how an economically
successful African professional
in Africa could be poor in terms
of the quality of his or her life.
For analytical convenience,
let me call this kind
of poverty psychosocial poverty.
OK? This kind of poverty is also an
impetus for migration out of Africa,
for migration to America.
What I am positing here is what
one may call vicarious poverty,
a situation in which
there will be migrant,
migrant African does not experience
poverty directly but indirectly
through the trauma of living in
the midst of grinding poverty
and of being assaulted daily by the
reminders and images of poverty,
economic collapse, infrastructural
deficits, and so forth.
The psychological torture and
burden of such an environment
of poverty can be as depressing
as actual personal poverty itself.
There are two aspects
to this phenomenon.
The first one revolves
around the fact
that no matter how successful one is
in Africa, one still has to depend
to various degrees on state-provided
social services, among them;
electricity, water,
sewage, roads and security.
As we know or as we should
know, these services are poor
in many African countries.
So, one is forced to participate
in the broader experience
of poverty and underdevelopment.
One's economic success cannot
insulate one from this.
Your quality of life will therefore
be poor and may motivate you
to migrate to America or another
country in the Global North
where social services are
delivered more efficiently.
In other words, there is a limit to
the amount of comfort and material--
that material success can
confer on you in Africa.
The second aspect has to do with
the ironic psychosocial trauma
of being successful in Africa.
In Africa, more so than in the West,
the successful professional is
confronted daily by sights, sounds,
and smells of acute poverty.
He is surrounded and
tortured by this poverty.
He sees it in his employees or
colleagues, junior colleagues,
neighbors, relatives, friends, and
coreligionists, as well as kinsmen.
On his daily commute to work, his
sense of accomplishments is diluted
and deflated by disturbing and
haunting images of destitution
and economic hopelessness.
These images nibble at his edifice
of-- at this edifice of success,
filling him at once with
guilt and anxieties,
and about what might have
been and what might still be.
The images erode the
joys of economic success
and make lofty economic
and professional perches seem less
secure than they actually are.
Insecurities, anxieties, guilt,
alienation, dissatisfaction,
and depression take a toll
on the quality of one's life.
I would argue that not a
few successful Africans,
economically successful
Africans, have migrated to America
to escape this quality
of life conundrum,
this unspoken existential turmoil
that hunts successful
professionals in Africa.
The paradox of being psychologically
miserable even while being
materially successful allows the
African professional to migrate
to America, not to escape
poverty, I would argue,
or to survive economically
but to escape mentally
and improve his quality of life in
the psychosocial sense of the word.
What the migrant is escaping
is a kind of poverty,
a different kind of poverty.
Not the poverty portrayed by
CNN or National Geographic
or in Hollywood movies, right?
So, increasingly, we are talking
about strategic migrants
and strategic migration.
Many of today's African migrants to
America are most strategic migrants
than they are economic
refugees, I would argue.
This is a not radical
statement to make actually
since African migrants are
generally well-educated,
even though the findings from
Professor Falola's work is--
complicates that argument
a little bit.
But generally, they
are very well-educated.
There are arguments that they
are also self-selected, right?
And strategically mobile,
people who are chosen
to be strategically mobile.
Whether they are beneficiaries
of the US Visa Lottery program
or students who came here to study,
like myself, or professionals
who came here to take up positions
in US firms and institutions,
many African migrants to the United
States increasingly do not fit
into the refugee-- the
refuge and exile paradigm.
Instead, they are a
pre-selected, relatively privileged
and prepared collection of
people who, for the most part,
were already set apart
to varying degrees
in their home countries prior
to their migration to America.
There are people who
are not representative
of the general populations
of their countries.
Their migrant itineraries and
biographies undermine the concept
which so many of you have heard, the
concept of model minority, right?
This prior preparation and privilege
rarely makes it into the scholarly
and popular discussions of
African migration to America.
Studies on African migration to the
United States rarely acknowledge,
let alone illuminate
this growing phenomenon
of psychosocial strategic migrants.
This phenomenon has grown
and will continue to account
for more African migration
to America
in the coming years given
the continued growth
of the African middle class in
the midst of expanding populations
of poor people on crumbling
infrastructure.
This dynamic of middle class
expansion, deepening poverty
and deteriorating infrastructure,
I would argue,
is key to understanding the rise
of strategic African
migration to America.
This migratory flow caused
by psychosocial alienation
and yearning for-- yearning, as
well as a systemic-- systematic--
systemic poverty and infrastructural
collapse, is likely to continue
as corporations and institutions in
the United States aggressively seek
out talent without regard to the
north-south dichotomies of old.
We already see that African
professionals in multiple fields,
some of them with experience
in multinational corporations
on the African side are take--
increasingly taking
positions in the global note
and relocating with their families.
I have-- actually I have friends
who used to work in these--
some of these multinational
companies back home who have--
who are doing very well, much
better than I am doing in America
but who nonetheless chose to migrate
with their families to America.
This is happening increasingly.
So, my argument is then that
we need a new vocabulary,
a new conceptual idiom to
explain the migratory choices
of these new African
migrants and to tell--
to be able to tell their stories
alongside the other stories as well.
In the African immigrant's
journey to--
If the African immigrant's journey
to America is a manifestation
of his efforts to make--
to take control of his life
and destiny while escaping the
conditions that diminish the quality
of his life in Africa, the processes
that make the journey
possible are shaped by forces
and narratives beyond his
or her control in America.
The African-- beyond his
But these forces are also
available to him to manipulate.
Furthermore, once he
is situated in America,
the African immigrant's life and
choices are no longer his own.
Rather, they are shaped
by the circumstances
and ideological positions
produced by the political dynamics
and the politics of
self-fashioning in American society.
Both the migratory process
and the way the migrant narrates
his experience are then constrained
and reshaped by preexisting
discursive regimes in America,
which perhaps explains why
in spite of the increase
in professional migrations,
strategic migrations from Africa,
the migration as economic
escape paradigm continues
to dominate perspective
and discussions
on African migration
to the United States.
This dissonance between the
complexity of the African story
of migration to America and its
simplistic reduction to story
of suffering and rescue
should be explained.
So, I return now to
my earlier question.
Why is the economic refugee
exile paradigm so persistent?
Why does it seem to overshadow
the increasing phenomenon
of African strategic
migration to the United States?
I want to conclude by offering
a few tentative answers
to these questions.
The paternalistic racial attitude
of Western Liberals construct
and legitimize certain migratory
stereotypes, I would argue.
It also privileges and silences
certain migratory narratives
and cause African migrants to become
active participants in this process
of silencing in a myth-making.
Liberal America's appetite for
dramatic African immigration stories
of escape, heroic, self-redemption
and exile confers validity
on immigrant narratives that
confirm these same stereotypes.
These stories reaffirm America's
fate in the foundational reputation
of their country as a land of
refuge and compassionate to rescue,
and of Africa as a land
of poverty and misery.
Other narratives of migration
and other migratory experiences
and trajectories are marginalized
when stories of poverty
and suffering-induced
migration are privileged.
The refugee is also a trope of
the conservative American view
of African migration to America.
And migrant stories and realities
that depart from the figure
of the refugee are unintelligible to
American conservative sensibilities.
Americans of the conservative
bend buy into the narrative
of African economic dysfunction and
therefore imagine Africans largely
as objects of American
humanitarian intervention.
This means that they
cannot imagine Africans
that are economically
successful in their homelands.
This in turn makes it easy for them
to discount stories of successful,
talented African migrants
to America.
It also makes it easy for them to
believe that Africans are desperate
to escape the horrors of their
homelands to come to America.
Here too, the gaze is
self-assuring because it works
to reaffirm the belief that
America is a generous, compassionate
and humanitarian country.
One that is receptive
to African refugees.
The template seems clear and
it's summed by its simplicity.
Africa is a land that
perennially produces refugees
and America is a country
that motivated
by Christian compassion takes
them in and nurtures them back
to socioeconomic stability.
The power of this idiom
of exile and escape has
in turn shaped how African
immigrants themselves narrate their
own experiences for the consumption
of American interlocutors.
Examples of this genre
includes Ishmael Beah's--
this book right here,
some of you know about it,
Ishmael Beah's "A Long Way Gone"
and Chris Abani's autobiographical
and semi-biographical works,
in which, you know, I kind of--
it goes into all this lurid quite
frankly untenable, you know,
quite frankly fantastical tales
about what he went through, what--
how he escaped and
how he was detained.
And we're talking about
penises being nailed to tables.
These are stories that
just simply never happened,
nobody can remember any
of these things happening,
but there's an appetite
for these kinds of stories.
These are the kinds of
stories that play well
with this paradigm of
the refugee, right?
The more dramatic, the more dramatic
you are in telling the stories,
the greater the market for it.
So we have this genre,
this genre that is growing.
So-- And we can talk
more about this later.
This entails-- So you have
sometimes the narrative basically,
the narrative pressures
placed on African immigrant,
immigrant autobiographers
like Chris Abani.
This is just a sampling of-- There
are so many works in this genre.
These narratives ponder to
Western audiences' hunger
for dramatic migrations
stories of African suffering
and American humanitarian heroism.
They cause these migrant
storytellers to make up events
and scenarios to fit
certain prepackaged Western
aesthetic expectations.
This entails suppressing
stories of migration to America
that lack this elements
of desperation and rescue.
The resulting stories of
exile penned by Africans--
African migrants in America
perpetuates the stereotypes
of helpless, displaced migrants
seeking refuge in America
and displaced alternative
stories of African migration
where the motives are less
familiar and less sensational.
African immigrants themselves become
unwittingly active participants
in a particular Western
trope of validating
and rewarding personal narratives
of African migration that conforms
to a certain valued template.
And I'll close by just--
This is just a screen grab.
If you go-- If you just-- and
just Google the name Chris Abani,
this is one of the first
few pages you will see.
And in this short piece-- I
don't know if you can read it--
it tells about his suffering,
how [inaudible] was
detained and tortured.
And a lot of Nigerian sleuths have
done research, people who lived
in those places, people who
lived through those times
who were involved in the
pro-democracy struggle
in the time that he claimed.
Nobody remembered him.
Nobody even remembered him on
the campus where he claimed
to have been an activist, where
he claimed to have been arrested.
But this-- If you go to his website,
to his personal website,
these stories persist.
He has this website,
widely displayed.
Wherever he's invited to talk
about his-- He's a great novelist,
don't get me wrong, fantastic
novelist, fantastic writer.
But, you know, he gets in the door
in most cases with these kinds
of biographical narrative
of how he suffered
and how ultimately he
escaped to America, right?
So that becomes the catch.
That becomes a way to get people
interested in his stories,
even in his literature,
brilliant, he writes as is.
You know, he cannot stand on
the merit of his literary works.
He has to kind of come
up with a story.
Everywhere you go, when
it's been introduced,
when his biographies are
being written, you know,
they'd always talk about how he
was detained for so many days,
how his penis was nailed to some--
the floor, and how he was
hung up on a ceiling and left.
You know, all kinds of
fantastical stories.
So, that's what I'm trying to get
at, this appetite on this pressure
on the part of Africans to tell the
stories to validate the stereotypes.
And I'll leave it at that.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> Toyin Falola: And let
me-- had to weigh in.
For those folks who call
upon by immigration services,
immigration attorneys, you find
many of these fantastic stories.
And Western feminists have
also contributed to it.
There was a [inaudible] for
instance, a [inaudible] of 10 years
when you can see-- because they
want to avoid female circumcision,
they should-- left [inaudible].
Even in regions where those
practices have stopped
since the 1940s.
I come from a part of Nigeria
where the Christian community have
abolished female circumcision before
I was born.
Or stories of witchcrafts
which are made up.
Look, I don't want to leave
Uganda because of witchcraft.
Stories of senior wives.
My father is married to four wives,
the first wife is about to kill me.
So as Moses is saying, these
stories connect to some kind
of ideological template
in this part of the world
that validates some--
a number of issues.
Then there are how
scholars also frame Africa,
a project that I'm doing.
And there is a way I'm
putting up this project,
that we have a generation of
scholars who have been writing
about Africa when they're in Africa.
And then, when they're
relocated here,
they begin to write
Africa differently
from how they are doing before.
In other words, the audience changes
and the presentation
of Africa changes.
I used to think that it's theories
that drew this because any time,
you think out a theory, the
narrative automatically will shift.
But locations also begin to shift
the conception of Africa depending
on the signals they are given.
And part of what we
want to do is also
to see how migrations do
change the presentation,
not just by great scholars
like Chimamanda.
The Nigerian Civil War is
50 years old next year.
But to find a generation of
writers who are not even born,
they are born after the war
but they talk about the war
as if they really,
really experienced it.
And how many of the things
that Moses has said plug
in to a bigger narrative
outside the frame of Africa.
Let me now call on Nemata Blyden.
And I want to use her
last name, Blyden.
Any of you must have
heard about Wilmot Blyden.
She-- Wilmot was Africa's-- arguably
the most distinguished intellectual
of the 19th century, who left the
West to go back to West Africa.
And he began to frame a different
set of arguments around Islam,
around the recovery of Africa.
And she comes from the
lineage of the Blyden family,
three greats or two greats?
>> Nemata Blyden: Two.
>> Toyin Falola: Two greats.
>> Nemata Blyden: Actually one.
>> Toyin Falola: One.
And her dad was a professor
of political science at Nsukka
in Nigeria and work
in very many places.
We are grateful for this long
line of African intellectuals.
Thank you.
>> Nemata Blyden: Thank you.
>> Toyin Falola: Yeah.
[ Applause ]
>> Nemata Blyden: Thank
you for that.
He always embarrasses me like that.
>> Toyin Falola: Sorry, excuse me.
>> Nemata Blyden: And I'd like to
thank Dr. Falola for including me
in this event as well as
the Library of Congress.
I'm going to take license in
defining contemporary by going back
to the 19th, late 19th
and early 20th century
to take a historical approach
to the subject matter by looking
at a few individuals
that I characterize
as immigrants from that period.
And what I'm trying to do
with this in a larger study is
to problematize how immigrants
and immigration are constructed
in American history, typically
privileging European immigrants.
So Africans are not black people
in general but for our purposes,
Africans are not considered
immigrants in some ways
in this country before the 1960s.
And I'm going to try and play
with that a little bit in my talk.
And I have these wonderful slides
which I'm not going
to use all of them.
And I forgot to include one of
them so I'm going to skip to--
Let me skip to this
for now, I'll come back
to the others if I have time.
In a January 1915 letter
to the Washington Post,
the African-American
Booker T. Washington,
head of Tuskegee Institute made
an appeal to the American Congress
and to the people of the United
States in favor of fair play
and justice in connection with the
immigration bill now pending before
the United States Senate, which
by amendment excludes from coming
into this country any
person of African descent.
He went on to empathically
state that the bill was "unjust,
unreasonable and unnecessary."
It is unnecessary, he proclaimed,
because only a few thousand people
of African descent enter
this country annually.
Practically, all of these that do
come are mainly from the West Indies
and almost none from
the continent of Africa.
Washington went on to cite
the 1910 census pointing
out that only 40,319 blacks in the
United States were foreign born,
and only 473 of those
were from Africa.
He further noted that the
immigration bill puts an unnecessary
slight upon colored people by
classing them with alien criminals.
Booker T. Washington argued that
the bill put unnecessary hardship
on countries like Liberia, Cuba
and Haiti by restricting the entry
of citizens from those countries.
Blacks from the Caribbean
and Africa, he said,
had proved as a whole
to be a law-abiding,
intelligent, industrious class.
Recent narratives exploring
the relationship between blacks
from Africa and native-born black
Americans have constructed it
as fraught with friction, tension,
rivalries and sometimes hostility.
Characterized as a
recent phenomenon,
this new African diaspora
has been highlighted
in sometimes sensational ways.
"More Africans Enter US
Than in Days of Slavery",
a 2005 New York Times'
headline read.
While another article
from the same paper opined
that the one million
Africans that had immigrated
in the last 30 years
provided a "New Interpretation
of African American History".
Yet Africans had been
arriving as immigrants
to the United States long
before Washington commented
on their presence in 1950.
And though not in the drill
suggested by the times,
they made a mark on
American society.
Although the large African presence
in the United States resulted
from the involuntary migration
of men and women and slave
on the continent since
the 17th century,
beginning in the 19th century,
Africans from the continent came
to the United States
in small numbers.
And the most studied group
of African immigrants
in that period are
probably the Cape Verdeans.
Most people know about that group.
Throughout the late 19th
century, Africans trickled
into the United States largely
interacting with African-Americans.
In the late 19th and
early 20th century,
many came as students
attending black institutions
of higher learning and frequently
interacted with black Americans,
allowing for exchanges
on various levels.
Africans often came to study
in the United States with hopes
of returning to their homeland
upon completion of their studies.
At institutions like Fisk, Howard,
Lincoln and Livingston College,
African students interacted with
their native-born American--
black American counterparts.
These interactions were often
guided by prevailing stereotypes
of Africa held by Americans
in general.
The predominant view held by
most Americans was, of course,
of Africa as the Dark Continent.
Largely negative portraying the
continent as savage, barbaric,
needing uplift from
those more civilized.
Because of the difficulties
adjusting to the African climate,
like their white counterparts,
black churches
and black missionaries start to
train Native Africans to serve
as missionaries in
their own native land,
so black missionaries
would encourage Africans
to come to the United States.
And these students came to the
United States a lot of times
under the auspices of these
African-American missions.
They offered African-Americans
the first opportunities to see
that the prevailing stereotypes
about Africa and Africans
were wrong.
Most Africans coming
to the United States
in that era would have been
educated within colonial systems,
missionary schools particularly
those who came and they mainly came
from the British colonies
in the earlier years.
They were westernized, largely
Christian, with some knowledge
of the society they were entering.
In fact, in 1899, Bishop
Henry McNeal Turner
of the African Methodist
Episcopal Zion Church noted,
"Everybody appears to be amazed
at their learning refinement
and general intelligence.
So many of our people
in this country believe all
Africans are mere heathens,
that they are paralyzed with
surprise to find such boys coming."
And I'm sorry the slide I left
out is on the next section.
James Aggrey was perhaps the
most famous African to arrive
in the United States in that
era, and might well be deemed one
of the first African
immigrants in the United States,
although he isn't often
thought of as such.
Now, I grew up listening to stories
about James Aggrey
at the dinner table.
My father hero worships
James Aggrey.
But in anything that he said
or in anything that I ever read
about James Aggrey, he's never
mentioned as an African immigrant
in the United States and
I construct him as such.
Born in the Gold Coast, later
Ghana, Aggrey attended mission
and colonial schools in the British
colony excelling in his studies.
He soon came to the notice of
missionaries and colonial officials.
And in 1898, he was sponsored
by Bishop Bryan Small
of the AME Zion Church.
And he came to-- was brought by
Bishop Small to the United States
in 1898 to study at Livingston
College in North Carolina.
Aggrey completed his studies at
Livingston, later becoming a member
of faculty and an administrator.
He remained in the United
States until his death
in 1927 marrying Rose Douglas, an
African-American woman from Virginia
and raising his family
in North Carolina.
Although he continued to highlight
his African heritage expressing his
love and devotion to his
homeland, he dedicated himself
to the improvement and
uplift of African-Americans.
He was popular with students
and had a great reputation,
a classmate of his noted.
WJ Trent, this classmate also
observed that Aggrey's influence was
"very precious and had a great
deal to do with the improvement
of the moral and spiritual
conditions
of the whole college life."
Having been ordained in the AME
Zion Church, Aggrey preached
in black churches all
over North Carolina.
He pastored two African
American churches
in rural communities
in that state as well.
His parishioners were mostly
poor, illiterate, rural people,
mainly farmers and laborers.
Working with these communities was
one of the most fulfilling aspects
of Aggrey's work in
the United States.
His biographer tells us, "it took
him out of an academic atmosphere
and introduced him
to the actualities
of life led by the American Negro."
Clearly, his relationship with
African-Americans was characterized
by mutual respect as is evident
from the many outpourings of grief
from African-Americans
after his death.
The bibliophile Arthur
Schomburg, in remembering Aggrey,
pointed out his influence and
legacy in the United States,
describing his contributions
to black Americans.
"At a Native American
school, Livingston College,
set in the panoramic mountains
of Salisbury, North Carolina,"
Schomburg said, "he
received the milk of kindness
and remained with his own people.
Later his loved joined
that of an American Rose
and made his stay permanent
among us."
Yet Aggrey also felt his difference.
And there are signs that
he was not fully accepted
as an American despite
his citizenship
and Aggrey actually was naturalized.
He felt the strain of being excluded
from the larger white society,
but he also felt slighted
by African-Americans.
His biographer writes that Aggrey
was accepted by whites more easily
than native-born blacks, making
it harder for him to get along
with some African-Americans.
He gained the respect and ardent
affection of a number of these
but in the minds of not a few,
the old prejudice persisted.
In 1917, Aggrey was
up for the position
of president of Livingston College.
He was not offered the
position and believed it was
because he was not a
native-born black American.
Though he later was
offered the position,
he declined it at that time.
He appears to have been
passed up for other positions
which he attributed to his foreign
status rather than his race.
In a letter to his wife
he wrote, "I am convinced
that being a foreigner," and
he puts foreigner in quotes,
"I could never command in any sort
of place the decent kind of a job
in this country that would
keep me to take care of you
and give the children the
education they deserve.
That is the way I see it.
You may not see it that way.
I am resigned to my fate."
He went on to tell Rose of
another African, one Norman Wilson
from Sierra Leone, living in
New York who faced the same sort
of discrimination, "Thwarted
at every turn in his desire
for advancement," Aggrey noted,
"that Wilson was considering
a return to Africa
because he tells me his brother
priest have been fighting him
because he's a foreigner.
He has had to go to the bishop.
He says he's getting tired of it.
They acknowledged his work and
his influence but they fight him
in an underhand way
because he is a foreigner.
Too bad for our race, too bad.
He has finished his
work for his BA degree.
He tells me he hopes this will
be his last year at this working
under such stress, the
everlasting foreigner nag."
No doubt their foreign
status was significant.
But in the 1920s when Aggrey
wrote their race was surely just
as important to their
inability to advance.
Like Aggrey-- And I
do have the slide
for this, if I can get back to it.
Like Aggrey, Orishatukeh Faduma came
to the United States as a student
and stayed becoming an immigrant.
Born William Davis in Sierra Leone,
Faduma came to the United States
in 1890-- sorry, a slide one back.
Here we go, sorry.
OK, I should stop touching it.
Faduma came to the United States
in 1890 to study at Yale--
It's doing it on its own.
Am I pressing it too hard?
It's not that important.
OK.
>> Toyin Falola: Very sensitive.
>> Nemata Blyden: Is it looping?
He came to study at the
Yale Divinity School
in New Haven, Connecticut.
After completing his degree in 1894,
he took a position in
the American South.
Like Aggrey, he married an
African-American woman Henrietta
Adams from Georgia, and
taught at the Peabody Academy,
a black institution in Troy,
North Carolina for 17 years.
Served as a missionary and
educator to African-Americans
in North Carolina for 50
years until he died in 1946.
In 1913, Faduma worked closely
with the African-American
Chief Alfred Sam and his Back
to Africa movement, encouraging
black Americans to return to Africa.
Though he himself never returned
becoming naturalized in 1902,
he spent the rest of his life
in the United States living
among African-Americans.
Both Faduma and Aggrey, like
many Africans in that era,
lived in a segregated south and
operated within a world in which
by virtue of the color
of their skin,
they were thought to be inferior.
Both men adapted to
their lives as black men
in a racially segregated nation,
at a time when discrimination
and racism were leveled at men
and women of African descent.
Both lived and worked among the
less privileged African-Americans
and saw it as their responsibility
and duty to enhance their lives
and improve their condition, which
was kind of a reverse, right,
with Faduma referring
to African-Americans
as his kith and kin.
His contributions were
recognized in the 1904 publication.
In an article profiling him, he
was lauded for his contributions
to African-Americans and for
his missionary work among them.
The article noted, "We question
if this Native African could
have made a better investment
of his powers had he
remained in Africa.
Africa is here."
Although Aggrey and Faduma settled
in the south, a few Africans lived
in northern cities like New York.
And over the years, blacks from
Africa continued to migrate
to the United States
for various reasons.
While relations
with African-Americans
were not always positive,
Africans found more
commonalities with African-Americans
than with the larger white society.
For the most part in
these early years,
Africans faced the same
discrimination from white Americans
as their native-born counterparts.
Although some highlighted their
difference and distinctiveness
from black Americans, what white
Americans often saw was their
black skin.
On the other hand, African-Americans
frequently welcome them as brethren.
In a 1971 interview, Bishop William
Jacob Walls, an African alumnus
of Livingston College where
Aggrey had attended remembered
that Africans were not looked down
upon us inferior by this campus.
For many Africans, the issues facing
African-Americans came to be theirs.
In the period before the 1960s,
perhaps because their
numbers were small and because
of the hostile environment in
which they often found themselves,
Africans living in the
United States lived alongside
and among black Americans.
Although they may have held
particular views and stereotypes
of African-Americans-- of Africans
before arriving as they lived
in the United States
for extended periods,
they relied on African-Americans
for an understanding of the society
into which they had come.
The 1965 Hart-Celler Immigration
Bill would change the size,
composition and demographic profile
of the African population
in the United States.
This act, liberalizing
American immigration laws,
would change to some extent too
the nature of the relationship
between African-Americans
and Africans.
Coming at the height of the Civil
Rights Movement, Africans studying
in American colleges often
found themselves in the midst
of agitation, civil rights
protests and marches, sit-ins
and other attempts
by African-Americans
to desegregate public
spaces and institutions.
Africans sometimes were
mistaken for black Americans
and face the same racial profiling.
As the United States increasingly
became a desegregated society
and one that was more open to
foreigners, Africans continue
to arrive on its shores in larger
numbers now finding themselves
with more options and opportunities.
Coming from newly African-- newly
independent African nations,
many saw a little need to
settle among black Americans.
As the number and composition
of African immigrants has grown,
so have the perceptions that
they, like other immigrants,
are different from
African-Americans.
While during the era of segregation,
black immigrants were often forced
to live alongside black
Americans, the new liberal
and relatively tolerable post-civil
rights America has given more recent
immigrants the opportunity to live
apart from and distance themselves
from African-American populations.
These black immigrants
are no longer settling
in traditional gateway cities
like New York or Miami but more
and more attracted to suburban
areas or as in the case
of Somalis in Maine to rural areas.
Despite the racial stereotypes,
some black immigrants
prefer settling among mixed
or largely white populations
believing that assimilating
with African-Americans would hinder
their socioeconomic advancement.
African immigrants also fear
the loss of ethnic identity
and they highlight their
distinctive heritage.
As immigrants, they have sometimes
lacked an understanding of
and do not identify
with post-slavery issues affecting
native-born American blacks.
As one young African
immigrant interviewed
for an Arizona news article stated,
"I don't associate
myself with slavery."
The article notes that these
new African-Americans lack ties
to American slavery and the inner
city culture frequently associated
with black America.
Many grew up in middle-class,
two-parent families and have access
to social networks that include
doctors, nurses, engineers,
professors and business executive.
Nonetheless, urban areas
remain important destinations
for some African immigrants
who choose or are forced
by economic circumstances
to settle in areas
with significant black
American populations.
These immigrants recognize
their status as a minority
and understand the
consequences of ethnicity
and race in the United States.
African immigrants increasingly
recognize the struggles
of African-Americans in providing
the world into which they came.
One immigrant remarked, "We feel
that those African-Americans
who were here before
were the pioneers.
If it wasn't for Martin Luther King
Jr. and the Civil Rights Movement,
we wouldn't be here
in the first place."
And as one scholar has
noted, black migrants,
unlike light-skinned migrants,
also face an entirely different set
of issues directly related to
fitting in with American society.
They must reconstruct and
redefine their identity in terms
of the American society's system
of race relations and hierarchy.
This, they sometimes
find difficult to do.
As one immigrant noted, African
immigrants sometimes struggle to fit
into black American
culture that has been shaped
by civil disobedience
and peaceful protest.
Many hesitate to speak out on race
issues because they fear deportation
or showing disrespect to
their adopted homeland.
They have, largely, not
integrated themselves
into African-American institutions
and organizations often
creating separate ethnic,
hometown or country associations.
This reluctance to identify fully
with the African-Americans
has sometimes led
to tensions between the two groups.
For example, at the turn
of the 21st century,
several incidents highlighted the
differences between the two groups.
In 2005, an Ivorian street vendor
in Harlem frequently harassed
by black Americans lashed out in
return, resulting in a street brawl.
While these incidents are
infrequent, they nevertheless point
at continued misunderstandings
between African-Americans
and black immigrants.
Stereotypical views and
representations of Africa continue
to be shown in mainstream media.
Negative images and ideas
about Africa still persist
among African-Americans,
largely because African Americans
students still are not taught much
about Africa, and when
exposed to Africans fall back
on old stereotypes of Africa
as the "Dark Continent".
Also at the heart of
African-American suspicion
of black immigrants is the belief
that they are competing for jobs
and other opportunities
and resources with them.
As the scholar John Bracey
observed of the Harlem incident,
Africans are seen as
another immigrant group
that is pushing past
African-Americans.
This is particular issue
of black immigrants
who some African Americans believe
are given preference for employment
by white employees-- employers.
Louis Chude-Sokei points out that
"whites have historically tended
to regard black immigrants
as a model minority
within a troublesome
native-born black population.
A good proportion of immigrants,
tend to be better educated
than African-Americans, don't
have the chip or racial resentment
on their shoulder and exhibit
the classic immigrant optimism
about assimilation into the
mainstream culture," he argues.
On the other hand, misconceptions
about African-Americans
persist among Africans as well.
The belief perpetuated by
the media and other sources
that African-Americans are not hard
working and frequently fall back
on the history of racism
to make excuses still
persists among some Africans.
As Bill Fletcher, president of
TransAfrica Forum commented,
"Many African-Americans
are embarrassed
or ambivalent about Africa.
And many Africans have
misconceptions
about the opportunities
available to African-Americans.
They often fail to appreciate
what the African-Americans have
gone through."
African immigrant attempts to
maintain a distinct identity
from African-Americans,
allows them the hope
of protecting their children from
racialization in American society.
Nonetheless, while African
immigrants in their attempt to cope
with the racial hierarchy
in the United States have
frequently claimed a foreign status,
they find it hard to insulate
themselves from white--
racial stereotypes
and discrimination.
Africans settling in urban
areas are more likely to closer
to the African-Americans
resulting in some tensions
but also providing the
opportunity for the group to learn
about each other and in some
instances to work together
in both social and political
causes and on an individual level.
Though misunderstanding persists,
in recent years, as in past years,
these groups have cooperated
with each other rather
than highlighting their differences.
And in most major metropolitan
areas and even in smaller suburbs,
African businesses and
organizations can now be found
as established institutions.
Whether they're hair braiding salons
or Senegalese restaurants in Harlem,
or the many African grocery
stores in Woodbridge, Virginia,
these businesses have become a
familiar part of the landscape.
They are patronized not
only by other Africans
but also African-Americans.
Likewise, the many African
churches springing up in cities
and suburbs all over the
country are drawing African
American congregants.
In other words, the relationship
between black immigrants
and American-born blacks is not
always characterized by tension.
Like Aggrey and Faduma, black
immigrants are also intermarrying
in greater numbers with
the African-Americans.
The children of these
unions frequently identify
with both parts of their heritage.
Furthermore, children of black
immigrants born in the United States
or brought here as young
children, more often than not,
think of themselves
as African-Americans
in different context.
Identifying with that-- Sometimes
identifying with that culture often
with some resistance
from their parents.
However, the American-born children
of African immigrants have
often been most successful
at understanding American society
than their parents have as evident
in their increased participation
in civic and political issues.
Recent events have highlighted
these commonalities and of course,
the most high profile
one was the 1999 shooting
of the Guinean immigrant Amadou
Diallo where African-Americans--
activists rallied around
African immigrants.
And more recently, many
African immigrants,
particularly of the younger
generation have been involved
in the Black Lives Matter movement.
More formal ties and
connections are also being created
between African-Americans
and black immigrants.
Just as Booker T. Washington spoke
out against the 1915
immigration bill, in 2006,
a group of black American and black
African immigrants came together
in Oakland, California to form the
Black Alliance for Just Immigration
to "support the demands of
the immigrant rights movement
and to engage African-Americans in
a dialog about the underlying issues
of race and economic status that
frame US immigration policy."
The relationship between
blacks and--
from Africa and African-Americans
has been long and continuous.
Since the late 19th
and early 20th century,
black immigrants have been
arriving in the United States.
Although at times they may have seem
invisible to the largest society,
black immigrants were
never invisible
to African-Americans among whom
they settled, worked, married,
and who were often their
entry point into the society.
Although in adjusting to American
society they have experienced
difficulty in assimilating,
the presence of an established
native-born black population has
been beneficial to black immigrants.
As more black immigrants arrive in
the United States, the definition
of African American will
expand as black immigrants
and native-born blacks
find common cause.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Did I run overtime?
Oh no, I have 11 seconds left.
>> Toyin Falola: Thank you very
much for locating this subject,
in terms of historical evolution
and contemporary tension.
For those of you who
follow the recent politics,
the recent election, and even
through Africa [inaudible],
many of you will be
shocked there is a lot
of support for Trump in Africa.
I would try to Moses,
for instance, was--
wrote a piece on why
that massive support.
And issues that you-- for those
of you who has come in to America,
a theme that was done
over 20 years ago,
some of what Nemata is
saying is captured in that.
But there are issues
that we have to--
First of all, we need a
long book on this subject
because it's used to
be from last kinship.
And then they're reframing.
And if you look at how we define
Africa today, how we teach Africa,
the person we hold the most is
Du Bois because he's the one
who actually framed it in
a way that we now accept.
If you look at the-- We've
rejected the Arab framing of it
as the land of the black.
We rejected the European
framing of it.
And Washington, DC takes
the earlier European framing
in which they lumped part of
North Africa with the Middle East
and it is Du Bois in that
generation who said, "No,
we are going to frame-- We are
now going to disconnect Africa
from Egypt from North Africa."
And that is what that
state in Africa itself
and the way in which we teach.
And you'll find when we go into the
academic understanding of Africa--
>> The restroom is this way, yes.
>> Toyin Falola: -- part of
what you'd find in literature is
that it was created
in London in the '40s,
whereas African-Americans
have actually created many
of this discipline long,
long time before this.
It is true that contemporary
immigrants are not connected
with the civil rights movement.
Many of them are beneficiaries
of the struggles
but they did not contribute to
the struggle and it shapes some
of what they see and
some of what they do.
But fundamentally, since the fall
of apartheid, we've been struggling
to create one common-- one
reason, one common cause
that will unite blacks on
both sides of the Atlantic.
So, anti-colonial struggles,
domestic US politics
and civil rights united them,
anti-apartheid struggles
united them.
But today, there has been
not a single one cause.
And until we get that one cause,
it's a little bit of challenge
to bring people together.
And we're searching for
that one common cause.
Maybe struggles against
poverty may be adapted.
But what the African Union has done
is to join Africa into six regions.
The older definition, it's
a continent of five regions.
But now, officially,
Africa has six regions
in which they now include
the African diaspora
as an official sixth region.
And how this will be connected to
textbook writings, on politics,
on policies are things we
have to pay attention to.
Let me now call on Ken,
right, you're next.
Is it Ken?
Where is Abdul?
OK. But Ken is next, right?
Yeah.
>> Kenneth Harrow: Yeah.
[ Applause ]
OK. I'd like to start
my presentation again
by thanking-- Yeah.
[Inaudible] so wait another minute?
OK. Thanking Professor
Falola for the invitation
and thanking Edward Widmer, the
director of the Kluge Center
and for bringing me
to this gorgeous,
gorgeous building in
this cold, cold day.
So, hello everyone.
I gave my presentation-- I
had lost, is this thing here.
Here we go, with the title "What is
African Literature or Cinema Today?"
Where do we look for
African literature?
Is there a-- Does that
look funny on the screen?
No? OK. I made Ama Ata Aidoo
with brown a couple of years ago.
It is quite emotional.
She was warm and greeting me and
I expatiated on how much I love
to work and had written about it.
When I told her I was interested
in the question of the production
of African culture by Africans
living outside the continent,
she got so upset, she
got up to leave.
And I had to beg her to stay.
She thought I was going to
accuse those living outside
of the continent of not being
authentic in their work.
And so the only way to
answer the question,
what is an African author would
have to be someone who grew
up in Africa and who lives there.
Such an answer today would
disqualify a very large number
of those considered major
African authors or filmmakers.
True, we are all made into
something different when we travel,
and especially live abroad.
True, the notion of authenticity or
autochthony is an anthropological
and political term grounded
in outsider points of view.
That is those on the outside
trying to define who is an insider
and where the inside and
outside begins where it ends.
This is, as Johannes Fabian puts it,
a colonial anthropological
understanding.
I detest authenticity, the word
and concept, the police who tried
to define it and especially
those in Africa
for whom it is the test
of genuineness or not.
So I was embarrassed that
she took my question so hard
and I made every effort to reassure
her I meant something different.
Well, what did I mean?
These days, I see large swathes of
African culture as being created
by those living abroad, from
Elach Nusani [assumed spelling]
to Chris Abani to Pius Adesanmi,
Aminatta Forna, Chimamanda Adichie,
just as I may-- might have listed--
might have listed Achebe in past
years, not to mention, Teju Cole
or Binyavanga Wainaina
and our own Toyin Falola.
This is not to say that an
even greater contribution
to African cultural production is
not being created on the continent.
But those whose works are
likely to enter onto the stage
of world literature or cinema
are largely living abroad.
And this is not new.
But it's testimony to
a changing context.
And I would argue now that the
literature of Taiye Selasi,
of Helen Oyeyemi, or NoViolet
Bulawayo, to mention three
of the most prominent women authors
is radically different from that
of women publishing on the continent
and especially women authors
of the past, like Flora
Nwapa, Mariama Ba,
or even Buchi Emecheta whose
own life had been marked
by beginning her career as an expat
in London before returning
to Nigeria.
From the outset, the great
Cameroonian author Ferdinand Oyono
was living in France and
writing Une vie de boy,
when Camara Laye was writing
L'Enfant noir in Paris
and when Senghor and Sedar were
composing their poems in Paris,
it was common for African authors
to have traveled and lived abroad
where they pen much
of their early works.
But that was a different time.
Their crafts were marked
by an upbringing
in a world radically
different from today's.
Marked by colonial or
neocolonial culture and milieu,
today's African authors
and [inaudible] often live
in Paris and London and New York.
Life and culture abroad
remains radically different
from what is accessible to
Africans living at home.
It isn't that African culture
isn't being diffused abroad
but the flows are highly uneven.
Some like Abani turned to totally
new directions of expression.
Abani now calls himself a
writer, not an African writer.
And his writing shares little with
those writing on the continent.
Others can live in New York's little
Senegal or London's Peckham Rye,
eat their thieboudienne or
poulet yassa every night.
Youssou N'Dour's concert in Bercy
is completely unlike the one
in his home club in
Thiossane, Dakar.
The food abroad for all
of us doesn't taste the
same as it does at home.
The music depends on its
audience for the performance
to acquire its full flavor.
What is ordinary at home
becomes exotic abroad.
And even when the name is the same,
the ingredients can
never be identical.
All of these presupposes a static
culture which is never the case.
The cook in New York might wind
up getting all the right flavors
of pepper soup, only
to learn that the chefs
in Lagos have found a better way
to make the fish taste spicy.
Something new is happening.
There are new conditions
of production,
new times, new people on the scene.
We are three generations away from
the early writers of the '50s.
Try to imagine what the
Biafran war meant for Achebe.
In his memoir, there was a country,
a personal history of Biafra.
He takes, which he wrote
in 2012, he takes us back
to a late British colonial
period before independence.
In a radical revision
of his early fiction,
he tells us the British
rule is a lot better
than we imagined it to have been.
Readers raised on "Things
Fall Apart"
and its truths must have
been astonished to read this,
Achebe with age turning more
indulgent had done so much
to shape our thinking about
those early missionaries
and administrators as
arrogant and small minded
and had given generations
a clear understanding
of Eurocentric colonial thought.
The adjustment is difficult.
Many of today's African
writers are in fact mixed race.
When Achebe and Emecheta and
[inaudible] wrote about Biafra,
none of them could have imagined a
heroine like Kainene in Adichie's
"Half Yellow Sun" whose elegance and
standoffishness redefined the image
of the African urban sophisticate.
It's Kainene I'm talking about.
You could say that about
Adichie too if you want.
She didn't care a whit.
That is Kainene now.
Did not care a whit for something
called evil cultural politics
and the character in the novel.
Instead she gave herself to a
struggle despite her wealthy
and privileged upbringing.
She married a white man,
a character the likes
of whom it would be
impossible to find
in the first two generations
of African literature.
If there is a single
story of the African
which Europeans have been
constructing for centuries,
simultaneously there is a
single story of the European
which Africans have
also constructed.
That construction dissolves
as Adichie creates characters
like the Englishman
Richard whose engagement
with Nigerian Kainene
somehow led him
to embrace a new form of commitment.
One not at all like what have
been required for those engaged
in the original struggle
for national liberation
as it had been during the
period of imperialism.
Now, the struggle entailed a new
configuration of national economy
like that of Eritrea,
South Sudan or Biafra,
for whom seeking independent freedom
from the autocratic
sometimes brutal state whose
by politics have reshaped
what's used
to be called [foreign
language] commitment.
Biafra was in fact the harbinger.
The language of the new freedom
fighter, not only the new African
but the new Afro-European comes
with Richard whose encounter
with other white foreigners
discombobulates their binary notions
of "us" and "them"
as he plays his role
as official spokesperson for Biafra.
Here's a fragment of the novelist's
depiction of Richard's encounter
with two white American
journalists who come
to Port Harcourt for their story.
"Richard was not sure how long they
had waited before boarding their
flight at Lisbon, but the wait
at Sao Tome for a relief flight
to Biafra had stretched 17 hours.
They needed a bath.
When the plump one,
sitting next to Richard,
began to talk about his first
visit to Biafra at the beginning
of the war, Richard thought
he needed a mouthwash too."
As we get the back story of
Richard's role in escorting them,
we're provided more
and more material
that signifies their difference
where Richard has become
one of us and less of them.
"Richard disliked him.
He disliked his washed-out green
eyes and his red-freckled face.
When he had met them at the
airport and handed them their passes
and told them he would
be their guide
and that the Biafran
government welcomed them,
he had disliked the redhead's
expression of scornful amusement.
It was as if he was saying, 'You are
speaking for the Biafrans?'" We need
to remember how Cesaire
problematized his own youthful
arrogance in thinking he could speak
for his people in Fort-de-France
and set that against this
reinvented global figure
of a spokesperson in
a post-colonial age.
Richard's whiteness changes
with his [foreign language]
but [foreign language] too has
changed radically into something
that we now express in terms
of the globally complex.
It's to be found not in the white
American journalist scornful retort
"you" speaking for the Biafrans
but rather than narrative itself
that prepares us to accept
Richard's reflective self-awareness
as he judges the failures of the
two American's paltry understandings
of his situation.
This self-awareness translates
into his ability to put himself
in their position so as
to judge its inadequacies.
This is mirrored in Adichie's
ability to put herself
into her white roommate's shoes
in her famous TED Talk
on the single story.
Or, in the shoes of her white
character, Richard, who can also see
and judge the perspective of his
fellow white racist journalists.
Does the skin color still
function to create compatriots?
Not so much in Adichie's
constructions.
Other wonderfully constructed
white characters appear
in recent fiction like, Aminatta
Forna's "Memories of Love".
Where the British Dr. Adrian
has become an inverted Bintou,
one who Sierra Leone has generated
and prolonged the longer he stays
in Africa, in love with Mamakay.
His and Richard's discourses
are new.
Their complexity more compelling
than the more one-sided
representation
of white expat experts seen
in Soyinka's early novel,
"The Interpreters", or Achebe's
white characters in "Anthills
of the Savannah", Dick with Mad
Medico, who still quotes Lord Acton
in establishing his difference
from colonials of the past.
For me, he's part of
another single story
like the white stereotype
figures of Mr. Brown
and Reverend Smith in
"Things Fall Apart".
In the Adichie and Forna novels,
the native guy now takes the form
of enamored white men like
Richard who are positioned as "us"
and "them" as figures who are
more than hybrid but now double.
They simultaneously are us and them
or at least partly so for as we all,
in fact, inhabit multiple
subjectivities.
In "The Thing around My
Neck", Adichie writes a story
about a Nigerian wife who joins
her husband in New Jersey.
Nkem raises the kids in the states
while Obiora commutes back and forth
to home in Africa and has a second
bureau as they call it in Lagos.
Nkem meanwhile has
become Americanized.
This is how Adichie puts it.
"She really belonged to this county
now, this country of curiosities
and crudities, this country
where you could drive at night
and not fear armed robbers,
where restaurants serve one
person enough food for three."
Still, she missed home.
Home is conveyed through the
familiar ties of family and friends
of language and the music of speech.
But it's the immediacy of
the physical environment
that brings her home
to her this difference.
"And when the snow covers the
yellow fire hydrant on the street,
she misses the Lagos sun that
glares down even when it rains.
She has sometimes thought
about moving back home
but never seriously,
never concretely.
She goes to a Pilates class twice
a week in Philly with her neighbor.
She bakes cookies for
her children's classes
and hers are always the favorites.
She expects banks to have drive-ins.
America has grown on her, snaked
its roots under her skin."
I like that last sentence a lot.
Adichie is sensitive to the
registers of accent, culture, food,
gender relations, taste,
and contemporary styles
that constitute the
American presence.
And her language records them in
her double consciousness at times
with ironic tones, but more
often in sheep pastures
and idiomatic turnings of the
phrase that render the perfect--
the portrait so perfectly
as to suture the native-born
American reader
into the African narrator's
perspective occluding the
non-narrative position, excuse me,
occluding the nonnative position
of the narrative subjectivity.
I'm using the cinematic term suture
to signify the identification
of the spectator with the character
on the screen as specifically
with the character's point of view.
This is accomplished in film by
positioning the camera in the place
of the actor so that we can
experience what the character feels,
fears, loves and especially
sees or doesn't see.
The techniques for moving
that suture from one character
to another involve camera placement
and movement as in the shot,
counter shot where two characters
speaking to each other are viewed
from the position of
their interlocutors
with whose perspective
we come to identify.
Who are we at that moment
of suture when we let go
of our own real position
in the theaters?
We pass in the moment of suture
into what Lacan calls
meconnaissance or misrecognition.
Because it constitutes us
as gathering together the fragmented
pieces of knowledge that we hold
of ourselves, especially those
pieces reflected back to us
in the eyes of others, whose name
for us we might wish to accept
as our own and thus
to identify with.
These moments of fragile and fraud
with the perils of being disrupted
by a name calling, we might
not wish to acknowledge.
It's most telling for the immigrant
who goes so far as to change,
not only her homeland but
also her home, her home boys,
her girlfriends, family, language,
status and ultimately name itself.
Call me John, not John
Pierre, Jack, not jackamo,
Joe not Juso, or Feller not fella.
What is retained here
is the new identity
which then obscures what's
responsible for making
that identity in giving it reality.
This is the ultimate
goal of the suture.
Its act of violence in accomplishing
the act of identification for those
who take themselves to be American,
Nigerian, Senegalese or French,
to be the holder of the green
card while occluding the presence
of the camera that captures the
eye of the spectator or that
of the narrative that
enchants the ear of the rear.
The violence that springs from
this assumption of oneness
in the suture consists in forgetting
the violence involved in the act
of constituting oneself
as one, as authentic.
The suturing of the subject in the
Caine awardee Binyavanga Wainaina's
"One Day I Will Write About
This Place" is complicated
by the radical violence that marks
the narrator's conflictual diaspora
sites of enunciation.
At one moment in the text,
he describes taking
the Hudson Line train
into the city while Togo is
playing in the World Cup.
Eyadema's corrupt family
has been put
in the limelight while
stealing from the cookie jar.
Wainaina's writing speaks of the
new Africa in a new global style
that captures the still
existent old world of politics
with the old autocracies
emerging in the icy waters
of new journalistic instant texting.
He's created a new story
not because of the scandal
of the west preoccupation with Afro
pessimistic plucking but because
of how we now desuture
ourselves from what we thought
to be African literature
and resuture the identification
with the reportage.
"International correspondents
with their long Dictaphones,
and dirty jeans, and 500
words before whiskey,
are slouched over the red velvet
chairs, in the VIP section
of the front, looking for the
story, the Most Macheteing Deathest,
Most Treasury Corruptest, Most
Entrail-Eating Civil Warest,
Most Crocodile-Grinning
Dictatorest, Most Heart-Wrenching
and Genociding Pulitzerest,
Most Black Big-Eyed
Oxfam Child Starvingest,
Most Wild African Savages
Having AIDS-Ridden Sexest
with Genetically Mutilatedest Girls.
The most authentic real black
Africanest story they can find
for Reuters or AP or Agence France."
Wainana invites us to
occupy cosmopolitan spaces
of language and geography.
In this third generation of
African literature prose,
clearly a new language
that is complete--
that was completely
inaccessible to Ngugi
when he imagined an authentic
cultural vehicle only
in African languages.
The new generation of
African women writers,
particularly those living abroad
have redrawn the landscape
of contemporary African
literature living
and writing globally their
works offering the remarks
by the occupation of multiple
spaces and militant gender politics.
But these perspectives have been
translated into their writing styles
with global settings in
Afropolitan postures.
Fatou Diome and Chimamanda
Adichie addressed gender issues
in ways very similar to those
employed by Aminatta Forna,
Doris Baingana, Helen
Oyeyemi, Sefi Atta;
they articulate subject positions
that speak directly to doubleness.
Fiction like Forna's "Memories
of Love" and Adichie's "The Thing
around My Neck", create
epistemologies
with dual standpoints both in
terms of the past and the present,
in terms of the global
north and south.
They have abolished
old-school hybridity.
Often it's through the
evocation of family memories
that the subjective locations
of immigrants today are
defined but at home and abroad.
This can be seen in
Forna's "Ancestor Stones",
Oyeyemi's "Icarus Girl", and
Diome's "Belly of the Atlantic".
In the latter, Diome
creates a telling portrait
of the dual locations
and double subjectivities
of the immigrant/emigrant.
She writes of her homeland in
Senegal, seen from the dark
of the night in Strasbourg where
she's watching a football match
which she will have to recount
in detail later to her brother
who has no TV in Casamance.
She too feels the pull
of here and there,
the tension of the writer's
pen that seeks to put it all
into place while there
are two different places,
inside here and outside there.
Here is how she puts it.
"It's late at night.
Strasbourg has lowered its
eyes to sleep or demurely
to avoid watching the
intimacy of lovers
and the nocturnal sorrow of others.
It's always at this time
that my memory chooses
to project films shown
elsewhere, under different skies,
stories buried deep down
inside me like ancient mosaics
in a city's subterranean tunnels.
Then she speaks of her
homesickness, guilt, absence,
and sadness whose lacunae she
attempts to bridge with words,
her words, especially where it's
connoting travel and distance
which she calls suitcase
words, words too limited
to convey the miseries of
exile, words too fragile
to break open the sarcophagus
that absence has cast around me,
words too narrow to serve as a
bridge between here and there.
Words, then, always used in place of
absent words, definitively drowned
at the font of the tears to
which they lend their taste.
And finally, suitcase words
whose contents are contraband,
whose meaning, despite the
detours, leads to a double life,
the me from here and
the me from over there."
We can read this passage as
that of a shot, reverse shot,
where two figures are in
dialogue and confront each other.
Here, Fatou abroad,
there Fatou home,
the two sides of Fatou Diome
simultaneously occupying the
different locations of
the traveler's suitcase,
the suitcase words, the suitcase
images, the suitcase lives.
In 1994, Homi Bhabha
wanted to play subjectivity
in the interstitial
space of hybridity.
In the present world of globalized
traveling, the time for hybridity,
for mixing, for mixing in,
is no longer available.
And doubling has replaced the
interplay of otherness himself.
As in a fugue, where traveling
is a flight from oneself,
there's a crossing, the
occupancy of a space
that separates two
worlds while belonging,
paradoxically, in both
and in neither.
An immigrant/emigrant always
occupies two subject locations
but the sense of belonging
in one comes to be supplanted
by the physical location
of the other.
Traveling shots in cinema carry
us from one location to another
in order that the vision
of a traveling subjectivity
could be normalized.
It smooths over the
bumps in the road.
Fatou says she feels free.
"I want to write into
everything that--
everything that my mother
didn't dare say and do.
Identity papers, all
the folds of the earth,
they didn't place a
birth here and now.
Identity papers, my
memory is my identity."
Together with her sense of
being a foreigner and stranger,
her subject position returns and
splits her into a double identity
of the newly constructed
subjectivity for the global frame.
"An outsider everywhere, I carry an
invisible theater inside me teaming
with ghosts."
Her subject location like
that which Gilroy defines
in "Black Atlantic" is marked
by the spaces she traverses
where immigration and
emigration cross with each voyage.
"To leave is to die of absence.
You return, of course, but
you return a different person.
On going back, you seek but
never find those you left behind.
Tears in your eyes, you
resign yourself to noticing
that the masks you'd made
for them no longer fit.
Who are these people I call
my brother and my sister?
Who am I to them?
The intruder who carries insider
her the woman they're waiting for,
whom they despair of
ever finding again?
The stranger who turns up?
The sister who leaves?
My dance between the two continents
is fraught with these questions."
In the story "Imitation",
Adichie similarly constructs a
dance between two continents.
As Obiora leaves Nkem in the US,
making frequent trips home to Lagos,
her world becomes divided
and split into two homes
that she cannot not occupy.
Nkem describes how her neighbors
try to understand their situation
as a divided couple but their
points of reference aren't adequate.
They would ask, "'Where
was her husband?
Was something wrong?'
Nkem said everything is fine.
He lived in Nigeria and
America; they had two homes.
She saw the doubt in their
eyes, knew they were thinking
of other couples with second homes
in places like Florida and Montreal,
couples who inhabited each home
at the same time, together.
When Nkem speaks to the
wife of another big man
about how she managed with a similar
arrangement, and whether she planned
on returning home to Nigeria, she
has asked, as the woman turned,
her eyes round, as though
Nkem had just betrayed here.
'But how can I live
in Nigeria again?'
The woman then explains that this
change was beyond her control.
'When you've been here so
long, you're not the same,
you're not like the people there.'
'How can my children blend in?'
And Nkem, although she disliked the
woman's severely shaved eyebrows,
had understood."
In the works of these
African women writers,
there's a strong undercurrent
of loss that draws attention
to their double subjectivity.
The pain of this loss creates
accounts for the world of this--
for the work of the suture and
the melodramatic effect to stitch
over loss through the doubling
of the subject's position.
In this new age, doubling
is the condition
for traveling subjectivities.
The African labor force travels
often dangerously between Africa
and the west, as the
same time as the wealthy,
highly educated Afropolitans
jet set between
and in their adopted
and original homes.
For the immigrant, the original
homeland becomes a ghostly presence
while the adopted one remains
a continually moving target.
The homeland is changed, it
shifts, they wear strange hats,
red on one side, black on the other.
That deluded think they could
recognize the owner of the house.
Where on earth is this
new-old homeland?
For Teju Cole, it is
a moving target.
According to the 2011 "Open City",
which is Cole's famous novel,
"Open City", the random house
blurb, he was raised in Nigeria
and came to the US in 1992.
Notice the hat.
And he lives in New York City.
His public persona now embellished
with his New York Times column
on photography is close to what
we imagined the protagonist
of the novel, Julius, to be.
Cole publishes for the New Yorker,
he is hipness, come to the center.
On the jacket of an earlier
novel, his earlier novel,
"Every Day Is for the Thief", we
learned something astonishing.
Namely, that the Cole
who came to the US
in '92 had already been
born there in 1975.
So that when the Cole of "Open
City" is presented to the reader
as essentially a Nigerian who
immigrated to New York City
like his hero Julius, we are being
instructed to read the novel as that
of an outsider who has refashioned
himself as a New York sophisticate,
whereas in truth, Cole was always
already that insider-outsider born
in Kalamazoo, Michigan,
of all places.
I see that as a spark.
Moreover, his website
stipulates he was born
to Nigerian parents
and raised in Nigeria.
So the question might really be,
depending on where one
stands, is he an Oyinbo or not.
In "Open City", Julius' people
on the father side are Yoruba.
And we know that in the best of ways
since his father is buried in Lagos.
On his mother side, it's German,
the side where the loss
appears most to mark him.
In New York, Belgium, or Lagos, he
remains distant, never [inaudible].
At one point in "Every
Day Is for the Thief",
he goes to the city market.
The essence of the city where
he is in search of himself,
or as he states, "If he'll
refuse to go to market,
how would you know the
existence of others?
How would you know of
your own existence?"
But the answer in the
market comes quickly,
depending on whether you were there
to buy tomatoes or garri or masks.
In this case, it was the latter.
And the distance this implied
came back to him immediately,
"When I started speaking Yoruba,
the man I've been haggling
with over some carved
masks laughs nervously.
Ah oga, he says, 'I didn't
know you knew the language,
I took you for an oyinbo,
or an Ibo man."
Teju, narrated, is irritated.
Not at the man's mistaken
attribution, who would want
to be taken for an
outsider in one's own home,
but rather at his relatively
correct automatic perception,
"'What subtle tells of dress
or body language have again
given me a way,' he asks.
This kind of thing didn't
happen when I lived here,
when I used to pass through
this very market on the way
to my exam preparation lessons."
Some subtle shift in the direction
of the west has now tainted his skin
color as the words for outsider,
white man, other, rich
man coalesce around him
in the very heart of home.
He is subject to the
same treatment according
to Saidiya Hartman whose
return home is to Ghana,
where her ancestors come from.
Life of Teju, Julius narrated,
Saidiya also an academic
is somehow betrayed
by her absence of local color.
And when approaching
Cape Coast Castle
for the ultimate homecoming
tourist experience, she is treated
with Oburoni, which she
glosses as outsider.
Of course, she's mistranslating.
Not willing to confess to
herself much less to us
that she's being called
the same thing as Oyinbo.
The urban dictionary
on Oburoni is astute.
Oburoni is the tree word for a white
person but sometimes used to refer
to foreigners in general.
The words often used by
Ghanaians in the diaspora,
when speaking amongst themselves
as a code word for white man.
Despite the relatively widespread
and casual use of the word,
its origins are not entirely
benign, the word Oburoni derives
from the word aburofo
which means trickster.
In "Every Day Is for the
Thief", the text self-translates,
giving us the authenticating
terms like oga while
at the same time not only glossing
but interpreting the usage.
"The masks are beautiful, but the
price he's asking is exorbitant.
I leave his shop and move on.
Other vendors call me.
Oga, boss, look my side now,
I go give una good price.
Others simply call out,
oyinbo, white man."
At this point, the
narrator turns tour guide.
"Young men sit in the interior
of the small stalls on rafia mats
or on low stools, their
limbs unfurled.
I move through the warren
shops, which like a souk is cool
and overstuffed, delighting
in its own tacky variety,
spilling seamlessly into
the cavernous indoor shop."
The writing here is become novel
souk, describing itself much
as we had expect from the
creative writing student.
And we remembered this is Cole's
first foray into long fiction,
written after his return
home to western Michigan,
and then Kalamazoo College
for his undergrad years.
Cole throbs on the notion
of home self-consciously.
His sense of being away then
back, though still mentally away,
emerges when he mentions
a friend named Ben,
to his Aunt Folake and Uncle Bello.
His uncle tells him, he's
a good man, this Ben,
pretty hard working, conscientious.
He's Ogoni, you know.
A young Teju narrator then
expostulates to his uncle
about the hard times the Ogoni
and Saro-Wiwa have experienced.
The response he receives is given
in Yoruba and translated for us.
"Aren't they the ones
who eat people?
Now, eating people might
be taken several ways
but what's most commonly
understood is that it's witches
who eat people especially at night
when their windows are left open.
Those most likely to engage in this
devouring are those nearest to home,
close relatives because that's
the Native Cameroon say,
there was jambe, the strongest
witchcraft is jambe [inaudible],
the witchcraft of home.
Teju, narrator, plays
the Oyinbo role perfectly
in his response to his own relative.
"Oh come on, Uncle, come on, I say,
why are you Nigerians
so fond of rumors.
We, what I mean is you, are
so tribalistic sometimes.
And anyway, don't our Yoruba people
also have some kingship-related
and grimly nonvegetarian ritual?"
Uncle Bello then left and
treats Teju, narrator,
to story about an albino
being eaten in Ondo State
in some fairly remote
region near the tribals.
Our youthful narrator's
eyes widened and we read,
"The particular Yoruba choice of
words made the story even funnier."
The global reader can
appreciate that.
The refusal to translate directly
the words [foreign language] leaves
us outside and inside
doubles in the sense
that we can't entirely represent
the local reader wanting to share
in the pleasure of the words
nuances, yet sure enough
as the outsider being
presented with his most delicate
of insider African
secret tale-telling
that we should not really believe
but maybe believe all the worst
of the tribals, whatever that means.
With the shift from you Nigerians
to we, what I mean is you,
we are asked to share
the joke and laughter
as though the author were
one of us or we one of them.
The outsider really brought
into the fold, the insider knows
that he cannot write this book
without a glance over his shoulder
to some remote tribal community.
To end with the words of [foreign
language], "I think it's important
to be on the right side of history
and that means coming to terms
with the fact that our faith isn't
written in a foreign language
but in our own languages."
But what is that language
for Adichie, for Cole,
for any of us who might
be each in his
or her own way not a
speaker of just one language.
Not someone who can lay
claim to just one home.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Toyin Falola: Thank
you very much.
I wanted to raise the
issues of audience.
Who is the new generation,
what they're writing for?
And issues on our own
African languages.
But time is not on us our side.
We still have one more speaker.
And we want to invite the
audience to also participate.
I want to invite him, Professor
Bangura to talk about Islam in terms
of how it plays out with these
new contemporary immigrants.
Professor Bangura.
[ Applause ]
>> Abdul Karim Bangura: OK.
Because of time, we'll make it
shorter than I had anticipated.
And hopefully, there'll be other
opportunities some other time.
But first, I want to just
to make quick corrections
on the brief bios you have.
I am no longer a professor at
American University for a long time.
I'm still with the
Center for Global Peace.
I don't want some young
person registering for a cause
and looking for me all over campus.
And I'm no longer also
the ambassador
of the ATWS to the United Nations.
This is what happens when we gain
information from the internet.
Some of this information
can be quite dated.
Just so that, I don't get
into trouble with anybody.
Let's contextualize.
The first thing we learn
about African Muslims
in the United States usually
begin with the slave trade.
How they came in tight ships and how
Soliman Job, this is the ancestor
of my mother from Futa Jallon.
So it's not just the Banguras
are the kings in potluck
but my mother also come
from very high royalty.
I see Peter is laughing back there.
And we already saw the
PBS series on Abdurakman,
which went on for two weeks.
And we all know the famous
story about the Amistad
in a greatly extensive learn and
give the Amistad lecture on that.
You can get out on the internet.
And we also know about the
Islamic connections to the Amistad.
We are asked-- even the pastors
that went to examine the busqu,
we are being taught
about Christianity,
about Muslims they
encountered in the place.
And we also know that the
Yoruba Muslims and [inaudible]
in particular were very instrumental
in the reeducation of the Amistad
when they returned to Sierra Leone.
And when we talk about the African
presence is very well-established,
is well-noted and many times,
many of these facts were denied
by Eurocentric scholars,
that we have myths
that Africans scholars were making.
We know about the great
documents of the Piri Reis.
We know about the Qatar Emir
[assumed spelling] even its own
document of China, and a lot
of other historical
evidence that has been birth.
But until the PBS and the BBC
corroborated what many African
scholars were saying, these things
were rejected as just myths,
that Africans wanted to feel good
and that's why we're
talking about these things.
And the reconstruction by
the PBS on the possibility
of how King Abu Bakri
could have sailed from Mali
to here is well-documented.
And yes, the PBS series on that.
And the great calling power as
you see the quote felt at home,
said I'm an American, though when
he stepped foot on Bunce Island,
he felt that spiritual connection.
And this is what many of us who
are pan-African is always striving
to get our people connected
on both sides
of the islands of the Atlantic.
So, quickly to understand the
African Muslim in the United States,
to contextualize the African
Muslim in the United States,
we go back to Hajar
or Hagar in English.
And being a Muslim, I'm
attending a Roman Catholic school
and served mass as an altar boy,
I was fortunate to study my Bible
from beginning to end, end
to beginning and won the love
of Bible scholarships and awards.
I love the Bible so much while
I still studied my Koran.
And I was fortunate when I study
in Italy to be supported by rabbis
and had no choice but in respect
for the people who give me food
and shelter to study Judaism.
And I then began to learn more
about this great African woman
and how she connected
Christianity, Islam, and Judaism.
And if you-- those of you who are
familiar with the Hebrew Pentateuch,
you can see the story from
Genesis, 13 through 17.
For those of you who are familiar
with the Holy Bible particularly
in Galatians, don't just limit
yourself to Matthew, Mark,
Luke and John, you begin to see
where the connection is made
that Abraham went on and built the
Kaaba, which we Muslims do the honor
as a very sacred place for our
[inaudible], our way of living
and how he constructed it.
Many, us, Christians don't
read far past those four books,
so we are not exposed
to that knowledge.
And when we read our Holy Koran, we
see the reconstruction of what is
in the Pentateuch all the way
to the Galatians to the Bible
and how Ishmael became the
father of the Ishmaelite
from which Prophet Muhammad emerged.
So, when we talk about
the African roots to Islam
and the transcendentalization
of Islam, we Africans,
we black folks are in the
center of this great experience.
And there's a great book Pentateuch
called "Libre de la Biblia",
which explains some
of these connections
and there's another great Italian
book "Il Vangelo e la Torah",
that is the gospel and the Torah.
That makes these connections.
And of course there is the
great "In Ascorto del la tora",
which is the listening to the Torah,
which also make these wonderful
connections, for those people
who are more interested in
learning about these things.
I say that to say, to give a
background of why we African Muslims
or black Muslims are very
fortunate, very fortunate,
because we find ourselves in a
land that has a lot of tolerance
for religion even though there
are certain schisms every now
and then that emerge.
And we can then say,
how has Africans
or African Muslims
made these connections?
We can begin by looking at the
transnationalism of African Muslims,
that is an African Muslim
that is African-centered.
And as the great scholar
Molefi Kete Asante
of Temple University tells us,
African centrism involves placing
at the center of every
discourse of the African,
whether on the continent or
in the diaspora at the center
of that particular discourse.
And we also know
that African-centered encounters
go back to the Tariq ibn Ziyad.
We all know that Ziyad
not only funded some
of the great Islamic schools,
the Moorish Science Temple
for example in Newark, New Jersey.
On that, the great Noble Drew was
funded by this Moorish gentleman.
We also know and Professor
Omoyeni Falola just mentioned
in briefly passing
that the great Wilmot,
Edward Wilmot Blyden
was very instrumental
in creating a connection between the
African and the Islamic religion.
Even going to the fact that he
preferred, even though he was--
is a Christian, even
going to the fact arguing
that he preferred blacks or Africans
to embrace Islam over Christianity.
And we also know that there
are certain challenges,
modes of challenges that
African Muslims encounter
in this part of the world.
They encounter continuous especially
in the areas of environmental
and attitudinal concerns.
We see how since the very vicious
terrorist act of September 11,
how Muslims, not just Muslims
from the Middle East and East Asia
but African Muslims also have
encountered the same sort
of harassment, the same sort of
deportation in very large numbers
than compared to all
the non-Muslim Africans.
We also see factors that impact
the success of African Muslims.
These include cultural, economic,
political and sociological factors.
We see that even our government
have gone to the extent
of imposing discriminatory
security checks for all Muslims
who would be entering the country
at 115 airports, 14 seaports
and these are usually entry
points for many African Muslims
that come to the society.
The challenges for
the role of the State,
we see that the State has
some challenges dealing
with African Muslims.
This seemed to be most predominantly
targeted at African Muslims
than other Africans, both in terms
of the politics and
in the legal arena.
And these were documented by even
the United State government itself
in targeting of certain groups that
send phones to communities in Africa
where they support
Muslim organizations.
And we had the hijab
as even legally stated
as a trigger for security checks.
But with all these challenges,
there are also opportunities
that have come with them.
Unfortunately, the time is not on
our side so this may be a rush job.
I apologize.
I was able to delineate
nine particular aspects
where new challenges have emerged
and where opportunities
have also come to the floor.
And Muslim and non-Muslim
relations but for us
to understand these aspects, we
have to not only rely on one theory
but in multiplicity of theories
and methodologies for
us to examine this.
When Omoyeni Falola asked me to be
part of this, I started writing.
Believe it or not, I end up
writing 85 pages of a paper
and I just started
scratching the surface
because there was a whole lot
more that I have to leave out.
And here, you can just
quickly see our definition
of the American family,
Christian white middle class.
The ideal family has evolved
though with the father who works
as a manager in [inaudible].
They want you to slap you.
They kiss mother if you kick
them on the sheen and 2.5 kids.
And as a recent methodologist, I
am still looking for that half kid.
It's possible statistically but
in reality, it is impossible.
I keep looking for the
kid without a head.
And that goes spell well
for the Muslim definition
of what a family is.
And so, they are sometimes
starting conflicts.
And even the hijab becomes a
problem, this social identity.
So what's our real work?
Of course--
Omoyeni Falola is now
checking for his time.
Cultural relativism, yeah we
have the hijab, the great Maryam,
the number one revered
woman in Islam.
As a mater of fact,
the Surah Maryam is one
of the most beautiful
surahs in the Koran.
And what we, Christian did
was we cut it into half.
Hail Mary, Mother of
Grace, you know.
It is good.
But I got to read beyond that
to appreciate the great Maryam.
Mother Teresa, we all love her.
She wears a hijab.
And you see all these great
African-- these Muslim women.
They wear hijab and some
choose not to wear hijab.
All of a sudden, hijab is
now something suspicious.
We also see challenges in
integrating Muslims in America.
And then you see, I
gave you a theory,
a methodology that I have meant to
do that and I have all the results.
So, whoever is interested,
send me an email.
I'll be happy to send you the paper.
So I will conclude by saying
that a people who emerged
from the great Hagar or Hajar, a
people who today have the leader
or the Chief Imam, the sheikh of
the grand mosque in Saudi Arabia,
have a whole lot of things to
hope for despite the trials
and the tribulations
and the challenges.
And I conclude with
a very short story,
as soon as Donald Trump won the
election, I have two web pages,
my own person web page on Facebook
and the African Books Heritage
web page, one of the folks
on my web page wrote,
"For you Muslims
who have been badmouthing
Donald Trump,
now that he has won the
election, is people are going
to be searching your Facebook pages
and you might find
yourself deported.
The next day, I went and checked at
those websites of all those folks
who were writing so many
bad things about the Donald.
And I am not lying to you,
all of them had deleted all
of the comments pertaining
to the Donald.
And two, three days later, I checked
all the folks who were not even
on my list that we just
communicate, those folks who were
so vehemently opposed to Trump
had already deleted everything
on their web pages on Donald.
But more particularly, the African
Muslims that I communicated with,
some of them are not
even communicating
with me anymore about the Donald.
Why? Because I think I was the
only African, if I can remember,
or the Muslim that predicted
that the Donald was going
to win this election.
I went in to write 11 factors
of why Sister Hillary will lose.
And I am, by the way,
a card carrying member
of the National Democratic Council.
So, for me, it was very difficult
to accept Sister Hillary's loss
because I'm the one that
coined the name Sister Hillary
that became popular when she ran
against Barack Obama
two elections ago.
But we African Muslims, as
I've been talking to them,
have to engage the Donald
just like we did George Bush.
George Bush came and said Africa
was not in his radar screen.
When the terrorist attack happened,
he has a war against Islam.
But we are able to communicate
and educate and exchange ideas.
It changes views.
And what happened?
George Bush turned out to be the
best president towards Africa
than any other president
before him, and definitely more
so than the one after him.
I thank you and I'll shut up.
[ Applause ]
>> Toyin Falola: Thank
you very much.
We now have to manage in
20 minutes for all the--
>> Abdul Karim Bangura: I
gave you a little bit of time.
>> Toyin Falola: Where is John?
You want to do this
or you should what--
[ Inaudible Remark ]
Yeah. There have been so
many issues on the table
and the last one on
specific identity.
And by the time, we're throwing
the nation of Islam into it,
you find more-- Mary, please,
you want to-- Please go ahead.
>> Mary: Happen to have lunch with
a group from Fulbright organization
and one of the women
who had come here
from Latin America originally came
on a Fulbright and over a period
of time, she became a resident,
US resident and citizen.
And she mentioned that when
Fulbright brought people
from another country, they
took great care to orient them
to a new culture, and then they took
great care to orient the community
that they were going into to the
immigrant, to the person coming in.
And I am wanting to ask you,
folks, whether you've experienced
that happening for
African immigrants
and would it be a good
idea if it isn't happening
and where could it
possibly begin to happen?
>> Toyin Falola: What-- Let
me start to answer that.
My introduction to the
US was made possible
by what we call Crossroads
Africa Operation.
It was a New York agency.
It was a sort of NGO, it was an NGO.
And in 19-- I was finishing
my PhD back then, 1980,
and they invited me to--
like 12 of us to come
and they took us to so many states.
So, I had that kind of
formal introduction.
Well, for most people,
I don't-- I'm not sure.
Bear in mind that the majority
of people come in terms of--
they don't come as professionals
like those first folks for me.
For those who come as professionals,
they have done their PhDs here,
the school system has
already done that.
I don't know what.
>> Nemata Blyden: I could-- I just--
I'm not answering her question
but I just want to say in light
of I think my talk was Crossroads
is an African-American organization,
is it not?
>> Toyin Falola: I think so.
>> Kenneth Harrow: Yeah.
>> Toyin Falola: OK.
>> Kenneth Harrow: In
response to that and thinking
of Moses' presentation,
it's kind of ironic.
We have a-- I'll speak only
from Lansing but I bet--
Lansing, Michigan, but I think
it's typical around the country.
We have a refugee center and
when refugees are brought in,
there's a good deal of attempt
to assist in the integration
into the culture and whatever,
life, jobs and so forth.
But when students come to the
university, we have very little
of that, unless they don't
speak English, then they have
to pass an exam in English before
they can go on and take courses.
In other words, those who were the
best educated get the least amount
of what you're describing
and- whereas those who come
in the most conditions
of duress get the most.
It's kind of ironic.
There's kind of inversion.
>> Abdul Karim Bangura:
In this area,
the best is the Ethiopian community.
Not only do they have a TV
station now, a radio station,
but they do even organize
an annual conference.
And they have a center in
Arlington whenever Ethiopians come
and they meet them at the
airport and then immerse them
into the society on what happens.
And they give them also the
support network, the transition
from being immigrants
into the society.
So I have to give the Ethiopians
kudos for that great initiative.
>> Toyin Falola: Questions
or comments?
Yes, please.
>> So, thank you very much
for the presentations.
And I have a question that
occurred to me, Moses,
during your presentation, but
I think it could be a question
for the panel particularly
Nemata and Kenneth as well,
which was thinking
about your discussions
of US populations of
African immigrants.
And the particularities
of the sort of US history
in which these immigrant communities
find themselves implicated
for a variety of reasons and
how that may or may not differ
if anybody can speak to this
from immigrant populations
that are moving to places of
former direct colonization.
And I was thinking particularly,
Moses, of your discussion
of the sort of US idealism
and humanitarian sort
of white savior complex
and the, perhaps,
historically inaccurate
sense in the US
of the US is not a
direct colonial power.
And so, Kenneth, I was thinking
of this in your juxtaposition
of a number of these authors who
are writing from different kinds
of spaces of immigration from
the US or from places in Europe
of former direct colonization.
>> Toyin Falola: Moses.
>> Moses Ochonu: Yeah, I'm going
to-- I think there is a certain--
there's a certain ideal that
operates within the US sense
of itself, the way that
Americans perceive themselves,
and it goes back to the
history of how Americans--
when it's obviously it's
debatable because at some point,
the US did have colonies, whether
you want to call them colonies
or not, that's a different question.
But it goes to the sense of the--
that Americans have of themselves
as people who have natural
solidarity for sovereign people,
for marginalized people, for
displaced people, and for people
who have been colonized and
brutalized and so on and so forth
because we too went through those
things and we came out of it ahead.
And so, therefore, it
is our responsibility,
almost a moral responsibility
to help others.
So, it's a moral discourse, right?
It's a moral discourse.
Of course that then
becomes almost like a--
It's almost like a blind spot
that develops out of that.
Becomes a blind spot that prevents
Americans, as I argued in my paper,
from seeing the ways
in which, you know,
they've basically constructed
an image of Africa as a place
that produces refugees, right?
And as America, as a
counterpart image of America,
as a place that receives
and nurtures
and rehabilitates these
refugees, right?
So, I think that sense of self, it's
a very-- it's a moral discourse.
And most societies have that.
There's nothing wrong with that.
I mean, that's the
root of nationalism
and patriotism and all of that.
Well, that then becomes this
discourse that, you know,
is then projected even on
through the immigrants themselves
and constrains the way
that immigrants themselves
tell their stories, right,
because they assume that, you
know, stories, these stories have
to fit a certain image of the
African immigrant, being a refugee,
looking for a economical
opportunities and it leads
to what examples that I give of
outright fabrication, embellishment,
of making up stories, of you know,
talking about impossible events
that are simply not true.
Because the more melodramatic,
the better,
the more positive the
reception, right?
So it works both ways.
It works under their hand
to reinforce this image
of America's humanitarian side,
side of humanitarian intervention.
But it also then becomes at least
for the purpose of this panel,
becomes a way to close
off an examination
of alternative migrant itineraries
that do not fit into
that template, so.
>> Toyin Falola: And there
are two complications.
The first is the unreliable
nature of the data
of immigrants fed into Africa.
It's-- I have read many of
them and they're so unreliable
because they deal with
exaggerations.
It is very difficult for individuals
to say that they are not successful.
It's easier for them
to do the opposite.
Even photography, you find someone
taking a photograph in front
of a car that doesn't belong to him
and sending the photograph
back to Africa.
So the slogan is, you either
make it or you fake it.
As for me, doing this
project, intensely data-driven,
the complications are so many.
The other myth which we have to
explore is that it is not true
as you'll find in literature that
movement to the west is far more--
Actually, internal movements
within Africa is far more intense.
So, when Boutros-Ghali left the
United Nations for the first time
and was looking for a new thing to
do, he was able to persuade Mubarak
to set up the Arab Summit.
And Mrs. Mubarak adopted it.
And that became, in one
word, drafted into it.
And that zone, Egypt,
Palestinian, Libya, that zone,
2 million people migrate
every year, 2 million.
So, not only do we have to
understand this damnation of Africa
in the west, I think we may
also have to begin to lock it
within Africa itself, especially
the extensive nature of the movement
between Nigeria and Gambia.
It's so extensive.
But what we tend to focus is
the Nigerians going to New York,
the Kenyans going to London.
Now, we begin-- We have to
begin to rethink some of this.
You what, I saw you yesterday,
at Georgetown University, right?
Yeah.
>> Can you-- Is this on?
Oh, yeah. My question is--
Africans coming to America and
the refugee status, the poverty,
that's right, the poverty status.
My question is the Africans who--
the professionals who
have found their homes
in America left their countries
but they left their ties
with the people back home.
In that, in America, the sense
is that you're an individual
and that you may--
you're a self-made person
and that you've pulled yourself
up from your own bootstraps.
Wherein Africa, you're a member of a
family and that family is extensive.
You have cousins and uncles
and grandparents but now, you--
from the presentation that I've
heard, now, you've set this notion
that you don't have
to have a family.
You don't have to have
extensive village or tribe, even.
You can come to America
and separate yourself
from what you had back home.
Is that a good thing?
>> Toyin Falola: OK.
Well, that is not what
our data is telling us.
The data is telling us the
opposite of what you said.
Yeah, because I-- when I was
introducing this subject,
I told you about the data
I'm collected in three states
around here, Pentecostalism
associations.
They're very strong.
So, take the Redeemer's
Church of Christ by Adeboye.
There is no American city where
that church doesn't exist.
Moses attends the one in Nashville.
I've been to his church.
So that-- So, he, if somebody--
let me give you one example.
If somebody calls me
Toyin, that's my name.
>> Bad example.
>> Toyin Falola: I definitely
know this is a stranger
because nobody calls me Toyin.
Nobody calls me that name.
So in Austin, they call me Baba.
That's what they call me.
Well that Baba, which is a father
and they're not my children
and I'm the patron of say
the Yoruba Association.
I'm a patron of so
many of this event.
They've recreated them,
the sociological time
of affection and kinship.
Many of these things
have been recreated.
So, what people have done is
to rework this community
back, only redefining them.
Since I came, we have
attended meetings
in Baltimore, firewood places.
So these things have been recreated.
Yes.
>> Nemata Blyden: I was going to add
that I think it's an
individual choice.
My students just finished their
final project where they had
to interview an African immigrant.
And I heard a whole host of ways
in which the various immigrants
that they interviewed are
adapting to and choosing
to live in the United States.
From the young man who's decided
he's done with his country in Africa
and doesn't have any
extended family to a woman
who has a significant network and
has essentially recreated her life
in the United States as it would
have been in her home country.
So I don't think we can
generalize in that way.
>> Moses Ochonu: Also-- OK.
I wanted to add briefly that we
also have to understand that,
even their decision to migrate,
whether their decision is
voluntary or involuntary.
>> Nemata Blyden: Makes
a difference.
>> Moses Ochonu: There's a lot of
people invested in their decision,
beyond the individual
back in Africa, right?
So that the choices that the
immigrant makes when he or she gets
to America, those choices themselves
are constrained and shaped
to a large extent by the
expectational economy back in Africa
in terms of what they
choose to study in school,
what kind of professional
they're going to,
these things are connected.
So there's no separation,
I would say.
>> Toyin Falola: Yes, please.
Ah, but later ask a question.
Last two people here.
Please, let's take
them-- who wants to.
Let's take-- who wants to--
>> I am very intrigued
about the forced migration
of Muslim Africans here
in the United States.
And when you started your lecture
about the Muslims, I've read a book
by Sylviane Diouf who talks about
the Muslims that were very important
to the slavery work
that had to be done to--
for the Africans here, let's say.
And I wondered-- And also,
you talked about Amistad,
I've never you-- No, I'm
hearing more and more
about that particular Muslim
collection-- information about that.
And I just wondered how that affects
all the Muslims who are coming
from the continent here, from west,
south whatever, because this--
the Muslims were a great force
to destroy as the type of slavery
that was held, hear and
in sight for long time.
And no one-- well, some people do
know that, but I just want to--
how does it follow through with
current immigration in terms
of the Muslim collection.
>> Abdul Karim Bangura:
Unfortunately--
>> Toyin Falola: Abdul,
please hold them.
They'll begin to asks.
>> Abdul Karim Bangura: OK--
>> Toyin Falola: So that
we're not disrespectful.
>> Thank you.
Actually, what I want to touch
on is and I'll be very brief.
I actually wanted to dwell a
little on more on what Professor--
Dr. Ochonu remarked but it
probably wouldn't be the time
to dwell on that at this time.
So, in the interest of time, I
will touch on what he said there
and then maybe a subsequent venue,
we could get into what he deals
with because I really
wonder if we have the--
I'll just abbreviate it by
saying that Africans who are here
in America, they've
done stellar things.
You look at the instance
of Lupita Nyong'o.
I think she's probably the last
Black Academy Award winner to date.
There is also, you
look at Victor Oladipo.
He just won an $84 million contract.
He is one of the-- these are
all Africans who are here,
they are born of African parents
so if they wanted to be identified
as Americans but at least
they're all born of Africans.
And they're continental Africans.
And he is a rookie.
He's getting approximately
$21 million a year.
The person who just designed this
new museum of African-American--
>> Toyin Falola: Adjaye.
>> -- history and culture--
>> Nemata Blyden: Adjaye.
>> -- David Adjaye, you know, I
think British-African architect.
Obama, you know, I can go on.
So, the stellar things
have been done.
So, my point, I just want to
raise is that Dr. Ochonu does talk
about the fact that we're
coming here and for this--
his thesis of psychosocial
strategic migrants.
I would like to get him
to that at some point
but the point is we are coming here
in droves and we're doing well.
So let's try to admit that.
There are still lots to deal
with back in-- on the continent.
So probably maybe it's time for
us to look at probably trying
to see the best of both worlds.
You know, like for
instance, Americans, those--
the [inaudible] for instance like
to live in New York when it's warm
and they like to live in
Florida when it's hot.
So probably, we Africans too
probably could consider, you know,
coming here for technology and
so on and then when it's all cold
like now, we're back in Africa.
That's just this.
>> Moses Ochonu: That was good.
>> Toyin Falola: I'm sorry.
We won't be able to
answer the questions.
I should have timed the Kluge
Center when I started but I was
in total panic about time.
So, I now want to close--
>> Moses Ochonu: Prof.
just one sentence.
>> Toyin Falola: Please, go ahead.
>> Moses Ochonu: OK.
My wonderful sister
raised a very question,
unfortunately, time did not permit.
Prof. Omoyeni Falola's colleague,
Denise Spellberg, wrote a great book
"Thomas Jefferson's Qur'an",
how the Koran shaped the United
States Constitution and the debates
that went around the Constitution.
What she was able to document
was Jefferson was learning
from the enslaved Africans under him
saw them worshipping facing the east
and asked them, why
you facing the east?
They said, that's because that's our
mecca, the Kaaba and Africa unite.
So there are so many things
Jefferson was able to learn
from the enslaved people under
him that shaped his own thinking.
It's not just the Koran that we
have here in the Library of Congress
that is displayed,
that we know about.
But she has done a great job.
Anybody who wants to know
more, please, get that book.
I'm not promoting it, but you
know, I think it's a good source.
>> Toyin Falola: That's
my colleague.
So let me thank Jason
Dan [assumed spelling],
the Director of the Kluge Center.
Dan was worried about the audience
and when I got here, I was so happy
because the audience is similar
to what's they've had
with other programs.
And hopefully, this
conversation will continue,
great books be written, a new
sub-field will be created.
And we are very grateful
that you are part
of the history in the making.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.